THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE. I WILL BE
MAKING SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED CONTINUE
OUR ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE I
GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO ARE JUST TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I'M GOING TO COVER
SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES ARE ITEMS
FOR THE DAY IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
WE'VE MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
pACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. FOR CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR BATES
AND SENATOR GROWTH WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WITH THE
USE OF VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM.
SENATORS I KNOW THE BOTH OF YOU
ARE MORE FAMILIAR THAN MANY OF
US WITH OUR NEW TECHNOLOGY BUT
JUST A REMINDER TO PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER AND THEN
REMEMBER TO ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO SPEAK. AT OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE. AND DOT
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
JOINING US- THE PARTICIPATION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH US SOME
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE PUBLIC. SO
FOR A PUBLIC TO ALLOW ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT. THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. SO
FOR INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAVE A
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. IT'S POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT'S GOING
TO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. FOUR SEVEN NINE FOUR ONE
ONE. WELL DISPLAYED AGAIN A
COUPLE MORE TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING. WHEN WE DO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. AS
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE ON. OUR THAT YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
EXCUSE ME. PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
NEEDED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IT IS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES WERE
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. SO JUST BE
PATIENT AND WE WILL MAKE SURE
EVERYONE HAS HEARD. ALSO I WILL
ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
OF WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY SO THAT WE
CAN CATCH YOUR TESTIMONY CLEARLY
FOR THE RECORD. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA I NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM ON A REMINDER
TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL NEED
TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE TO
ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE
. AND- WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
LET ME ASK YOU TO CALL THE ROLL
. KAMLAGER HERE LONGER HERE
LEHRER HERE THEY'RE HERE ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE MAY. HOME. I'M
HERE BE PUT. GROW THAT GROWTH
PRESENT GROWTH PRESENT THANK YOU
I WE ARE CLEARLY ARE GOOD AND
KNOW HOW TO DO THIS WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS SENATORS GROVE AND
VICE CHAIR BATES ARE ON SCREEN-
WHEN WE GO TO THEM AND RECORD
THEIR VOTES AND IT TAKES JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME BUT I
BELIEVE IT IS DEFINITELY WORTH
IT TO HAVE THE PARTICIPATION AND
SO TO THE APPOINTEES THAT ARE
WAITING IT MAY SEEM A LITTLE
SLOWER THAN NORMAL BUT I
GUARANTEE YOU ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE VERY INTERESTED
IN THE APPOINTMENT PROCESS. AND
HEARING FROM YOU I WILL ALSO
NOTE THAT- YOU KNOW WE LIKE TO
CHALLENGE OURSELVES- WE HAVE
MULTIPLEMEETINGS GOING ON AT
THE SAME TIME IN WHICH- SENATOR
LAYERED HAS TO GO PERCENT OF
BILL AND A SENATOR COM LOCKER IS
ON A BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE. AND
THEN OF COURSE I'VE GOT MY
COLLEAGUES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY BUT WE ARE GOING TO.
MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO
MAKE SURE WE GIVE US. THE DUE
DILIGENCE WE NEED TO THESE
APPOINTMENTS THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PUT FORWARD AND THAT WE
ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE.
SO WITH THAT AND WHILE I HAVE A
QUORUM LET ME ASK IF I CAN OUR
TAKE UP ITEM TO REFERENCE OF
BILLS AND GET A MOTION FROM ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES. I MOVED THE
BILL. SENATOR LAYERED HAS MOVED
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. KAMLAGER HI MARGARET I
LAYERED HI THERE AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE. WE'RE
GONNA GET YOU ON SCREEN VICE
CHAIR. AND PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME V. ITEM NUMBER THE ITEM AND
YOUR VOTE. WOULD YOU PLEASE
RESTATE THE ITEM NUMBER WE HAVE
SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE PACKET
THAT CAME TO ME I ABSOLUTELY
YEAH- IT IS ITEM NUMBER TO
REFERENCE OF BILLS THE MOTION
WAS BY SENATOR LAYERED- SENATOR
BATES I ITEM NUMBER TWO SOME HI
THANK YOU BATES I. GROVE GROSS
AND GORY SEARLES REFERENCE TO
BILLS TO COMMITTEES I ITEM TWO
GROVE I. THANK YOU FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE ZERO COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
SO MUCH WITH THAT WE ARE GOING
TO TURN THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
THAT'S ITEM ONE EIGHTH THROUGH
C. AND THE APPOINTMENTS OF
MEMBERS OF THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION. LET ME WELCOME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
THREE INDIVIDUALS MS JACQUELYN
M. HOLSTER KARMI C. AND I'M
GONNA HOPE I SAID THAT RIGHT AND
YOU'LL CORRECT ME WHEN YOU
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. MISS
SAMANTHA J. MURRAY J. D. N. MISS
ERIKA ZABALETA PHD LET ME
WELCOME EACH OF YOU. WE WILL
TAKE UP INTRODUCTIONS IN THAT
WATER- THAT I STATED YOUR NAME
I'LL CALL ON YOU- INDIVIDUALLY
IN A SECOND BUT I WANT TO. LET
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE FREE TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU OR
THAT YOU WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
AND THEN MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE- AND AFTER EACH OF YOU HAVE
BEEN. INTRODUCED PROPERLY AND
HAD A CHANCE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ANYONE MAKE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS THEN WE WILL GO TO
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS TO YOU.
INDIVIDUALLY OR AS A GROUP AND
ALL MANAGE THAT. SO WITH THAT
LET ME FIRST WELCOME MISS
HOLLISTER CARMIE CNN PLEASE
AGAIN MAKE SURE YOU TELL ME HOW
TO SAY YOUR NAME I HATE TO DO IT
WRONG. SO GO AHEAD WELCOME AND
ANY INTRODUCTION TO LIKE TO MAKE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- HONORABLE
CHAIR ATKINS VICE CHAIR BATES
AND SENATORS. MY NAME IS JACKIE
HOSLER KARMAZIN- IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE HERE TODAY FOR MY SECOND
CONFIRMATION HEARING I WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE- MY DAUGHTER
WHO IS WATCHING. SHE'S WATCHING
THE LIVE STREAM HER NAME IS
HEATHER HEATHER HOSLER. I'M I
HAVE A LARGE FAMILY SO I WON'T
GO INTO ALL THE NAMES BUT I'M
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND ALL RIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO GO AHEAD MAKE MY
OPENING STATEMENT NOW YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY. AND AS YOU MAY
KNOW I WAS FIRST APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN IN. AND CONFIRMED
BY THE SENATE ROLES IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN I'M REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO MY SECOND TERM. MY
FIRST TERM GOALS FOCUSED ON
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
ENVIRONMENT WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND PROMOTING
FORUMS FOR DISCUSSION. I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING CAN
WITH THE HAND GEN AND ANGLING
COMMUNITY. CONSERVATION
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND TRIBAL
NATIONS AND COMMUNITIES. I WORK
HARD TO LISTEN TO ALL SIDES OF
THE MANY CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES
BROUGHT BEFORE THE COMMISSION. I
HAVE ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING TO CO CREATE THE
COMMISSION'S TRIBAL COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST COST TRAVEL
CONSULTATION POLICY THE FIRST CO
MANAGEMENT. VISION STATEMENT AND
DEFINITION. THE COMMISSION NOW
ALSO HAS THE SUPPORT OF A FULL
TIME TRIBAL ADVISOR ON STAFF
THESE MILESTONES HAVE BEEN LONG
OVERDUE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET ME TURN NOW TO
MISS A SAMANTHA J. MURRAY JD
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE MY FAMILY
WHO'S WATCHING AND ESPECIALLY MY
DAUGHTER WILL LAST WHO IS SEVEN
AND MY SON WRITER WHO'S NINE.
THANKS TO ALL MY FAMILY FOR
THEIR SUPPORT MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA MARIE AND I'M CURRENTLY
THE VICE PRESIDENTS OF THE FISH
AND GAM COMMISSION I WAS HERE
BEFORE YOU JUST TWO SHORT YEARS
AGO ALTHOUGH IT FEELS A BIT LIKE
A LIFETIME AGO WHEN WE HAD THAT
CONFIRMATION HEARING IT WAS THE
LAST WORK TRIP THAT I TOOK
BEFORE THAT COVERED PANDEMIC- I
DO ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
JOINING FROM NORTH COUNTY SAN
DIEGO. ON THE TRADITIONAL AND
ANCESTRAL TERRITORY OF THE
COMMAND NATION THAT'S CERTAINLY
RELEVANT TO THE WORK WE DO ON
THE COMMISSION TOLD CALIFORNIA'S
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND THEIR
HABITATS IN THE PUBLIC TRUST. I
AM HONORED TO SERVE ON THIS
COMMISSION WITH AN ABSOLUTELY
STELLAR STAFF AND FOR TALENTED
THOUGHTFUL COMMISSIONERS. AND
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR POINTINGME TO THIS
POSITION. WHICH I SORT OF FEEL
LIKE I'VE BEEN PREPARING FOR MY
ENTIRE LIFE. I GREW UP IN A
SMALL TOWN IN MINNESOTA CALLED
WINONA WHICH IS RIGHT ON THE
MISSISSIPPI RIVER WHERE AS A KID
I WON FIFTEEN TROPHIES FROM AS
YOUNG AS SIX YEARS OLD. I GREW
UP POSING FOR PHOTOS NEXT TO
GUIDED DEER HANGING IN MY GARAGE
IN A HOUSE FULL OF PRINCE
SPIDERS AND GRILL SETS ONE AT
DUCKS UNLIMITED FUNDRAISERS.
NEEDLESS TO SAY I GREW UP WITH A
STRONG CONNECTION TO AND DEEP
RESPECT FOR THE HUNTERS AND
FISHERMEN OF THE U. S. AND I
UNDERSTAND FIRSTHAND THE
CRITICAL ROLE THESE COMMUNITIES
PLAN CONSERVATION. TODAY I TEACH
AND MENTOR GRADUATE STUDENTS
EXPLORING NATURAL RESOURCE
CHALLENGES FROM MULTIPLE
DISCIPLINES WHERE WE CONSIDER
THE LAW THE SCIENCE ECONOMICS.
AND THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
IMPLICATIONS OF OCEAN
CONSERVATION ISSUES. IN MY VIEW
WE ARE SORT OF OUT OF SILVER
BULLET FIXES TO THE CHALLENGES
WE FACE IN OUR OCEAN AND LAND.
SOLUTIONS TODAY MUST BE
INTERDISCIPLINARY AND REQUIRE
INNOVATION AND NEW ONES
CREATIVITY AND I'D ARGUE A WHOLE
LOT OF EMPATHY. I WORK HARD TO
BRING THIS HISTORY THIS
EXPERIENCE AND THIS APPROACH TO
MY WORK ON THE COMMISSION EVERY
DAY AND I'M HUMBLED BY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO. THANKS SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE- OF
FINALLY LET'S GO TO MRS OF
ALETTA AND ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE FOLKS TO MAKE
COMMENTS WELCOME. THANK YOU
MADAM PRETENDING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO START OUT
BY INTRODUCING MY HUSBAND BERNIE
pFIFTEEN. AND MY DAUGHTER NADIA
WHO IS TWELFTH THIS IS STRANGE
TO DO AN EXAM BUT- I WANTED TO
BE HERE ALSO ATTENDING REMOTELY
OR MY OLDER SON'S BEEN IN RATE
AND MY PARENTS UMBERTO UNSEREM
SEVERAL FM A SIBLINGS ALEXIS AND
MARCELO. MY PHD MENTOR STANFORD
EMERITUS PROFESSOR HOW MANY IN
MANY OF MY WONDERFUL COLLEAGUES
AND CURRENT AND FORMER STUDENTS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I JOIN. FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TEN MONTHS AGO AND
I'M HONORED AND GRATEFUL TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN THIS
ROLE WHICH CONNECTS MANY PARTS
OF MY WORK AND LIFE. MY PARENTS
IMMIGRATED TO THE U. S. FROM TWO
DIFFERENT CONTINENTS AND I GREW
UP LEARNING FIRST HAND ABOUT THE
VALUE. OF DIVERSE CULTURES AND%
pWERE SCARCE IN MY BIG CITY HOME
NATURAL SPACES WERE ALSO
PRECIOUS TO ME MOST FASCINATED
BY WILDLIFE ESPECIALLY BY TRYING
TO CATCH IT. AND IN COLLEGE I
REALIZED THAT I WAS CAPTIVATED
NOT JUST BY THE WILDLIFE BUT
EVEN MORE BY THE DIVERSITY OF
WAYS THAT PEOPLE RELATE TO IT.
AND DEPEND ON IT. SO A LOT OF MY
RESEARCH AS A GRADUATE STUDENT
AND AS A YOUNG PROFESSOR
ADDRESSED HOW HUNTERS RELATE TO
THE ANIMALS THEY HUNT. IN THE
PLACES THEY CONTENT. AND HOW TO
PROTECT SUBSISTENCE LIVELIHOODS
AS WELL FIRE AND CLIMATE CHANGE
ALTERED THE FOREST AROUND
TRADITIONAL HUNTING AND FISHING
COMMUNITIES. TODAY I AM A
PROFESSOR OF ECOLOGY A FIELD
SCIENTIST AN AVID HUNTER I'M
SORRY HIKER FISHER AND
NATURALIST. MY CAREER'S BEEN
ABOUT CONSERVING BIODIVERSITY
AND ITS BENEFITS TO PEOPLE. AND
ABOUT SHARING THAT RICHNESS AND
THAT WORK WITH OTHER
CALIFORNIANS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS INCLUDING THE MANY
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THAT I'VE
TAUGHT AT UC SANTA CRUZ. I'VE
USED DURING LAND WATER AND
WILDLIFE WHICH I THE FOUNDATION
FOR OUR HEALTH AND WELL BEING
AS- THE MOST IMPORTANT WORK OF
OUR GENERATION AND SOME HONOR TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE THAT. THANK SO MUCH SO
APPRECIATE YOUR SPOUSE AND I.
YOUNG PEOPLE BE AND WILLING TO
BE ON SCREEN AND PUT IN A VOTE
OF CONFIDENCE FOR THEIR MOM- I'M
GOING TO TURN OUR FIRST TWO US
SENATOR LAYERED AND- HOPEFULLY
WILL HAVE TIME FOR. ALL SENATORS
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- I APOLOGIZE UP TO STEP UP
ABOUT TEN MINUTES IN CASE PEOPLE
ARE STILL ANSWERING BUT IT IS
GREAT I KNOW ALL THREE OF YOU A
I WAS INVOLVED WITH. JACKIE WHEN
SHE WAS APPOINTED A CEMENT THE
WORKED ON BRING PROTECTION AND-
AND I JUST LEARNED WHO ERICA IS
MARRIED TO I DID NOT REALIZE
THAT SO- AND SHE IS DOOMING FROM
NOT FAR FROM MY HOME I WISH I
WAS WHERE SHE WAS- TODAY. I
THOUGHT I HAD A VERY GOOD
MEETING WITH ALL OF YOU
YESTERDAY. AND I THOUGHT THE ONE
THING I WOULD ASK ABOUT- BECAUSE
I'M UNCOMFORTABLE WITH ALL THREE
OF YOU AND WHAT THE RESPONSES
WERE AND WHAT YOUR LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT IS AND WHAT YOU BRING
TO THE COMMISSION. BUT THE
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS. OR
SOMETHING THAT FALL WITH IN THIS
THEY'VE BEEN VERY CONTENTIOUS
AND THEY ARE NOT AS CONTENTIOUS
ANYMORE. AND I WAS GOING TO ASK
EACH OF YOU TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR COMMITMENT AND I KNOW
THAT THEIR ISSUES OF CO
MANAGEMENT. AND THERE'S ISSUES
OF DEFINING SUSTENANCE THAT
WHAT'S IN THE AGREEMENT. WITH
TRIBES TO BRING THEM INTO
SUPPORT TO DEAL WITH THEIR NEEDS
WITH MARINE PROTECTED AREAS AND
I WAS HOPING EACH ONE OF YOU.
ARE COULD TALK ABOUT THAT AND
MAYBE WOULD BE GOOD TO GO IN THE
ORDER THAT YOU PRESENTED SO IT'S
CLEAR WHO'S CALLING AND SO BEGIN
WITH JACKIE GO TO SAMANTHA AND
THEN. I TOOK CARE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED- AS YOU KNOW I
HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY. WITHIN
THE MARINE LIFE PROTECTION ACT
EARLY DAYS. BEGINNING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN. AND BEING INVOLVED WITH
THE AND ON THE NORTH COAST
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER BOARD FOR
IN HERE IS- I DO HAVE A STRONG
COMMITMENT. TO SEEING SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES- AND AS YOU KNOW. DID
YOU CHANNEL MANAGEMENT REVIEW AT
THE TEN YEAR A REVIEW OF. WE'RE
OUT WITH MPA'S IS LOOKING
POSITIVE- WORKING WITH THE
TRIBES DURING THIS TIME WE HAVE
DONE EXTENSIVE WORK. IN OUR
TRIBALLY. DOING RESEARCH AND
PROJECTS. GROUPING TRIBES
TOGETHER ON OUR TRAVEL COMMITTEE
IT IS ALWAYS A TO A TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION- I BELIEVE THAT WE
ARE GOING TO SEE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES IN RESOURCES
REBOUNDING- BUT AGAIN MY WORK
HAS BEEN TRIBALLY WITHIN THE MPA
AREAS WE WERE ABLE TO GET
TRAVEL- THE SUBSISTENCE WITHIN
SOME STATE MARINE CONSERVATION
AREAS. AND I JUST LOOK FORWARD
TO THOSE FUTURE OUTCOMES IN THE
COMMISSION WILL BE LOOKING OUT
THAT REVIEW- AND WITHOUT. OUT
COMING IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWO
. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
MARIE. YES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION SENATOR LAYERED SO
I TOO WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
MARINE LIFE PROTECTION ACT
PROCESS I THINK STARTING JUST AT
THE END OF THE CENTRAL COAST
PROCESS IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I
SAT ON THE REGIONAL STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS- FOR THE NORTH CENTRAL
COAST. AND SO I TO SHARE A
COMMITMENT TO THAT- TO THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR OUR NETWORK OF
A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS. IN TERMS OF THE
DECATUR MANAGEMENT REVIEW YOU
KNOW THE GOOD NEWS IS WE'VE BEEN
COLLECTING INFORMATION SINCE THE
BEGINNING WE'VE BEEN VERY LUCKY.
DUE TO THE STATES AS WELL AS
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS TO
HAVE ON GOING BASELINE AND LONG
TERM MONITORING. SO WE KNOW THAT
IN OUR MPAS WERE YOU KNOW IT'S
EARLY DAYS BUT WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE POSITIVE RESULTS AND RESULTS
ARE PROMISING WE'RE GETTING
BIGGER MORE FISH OF GREATER
DIVERSITY. WITHIN MPA BOUNDARIES
ESPECIALLY IN OUR OLDER MPAS
LIKE THOSE AT POINT LOBOS. AND
WE'VE BEEN GETTING DOCUMENTED
CASES OF SPILLOVER WHICH IS HARD
TO DOCUMENT. ABOUT THE DNA IS
HELPFUL FOR THAT. AND AND IN
SOME CASES RESILIENCY OF
ECOSYSTEMS IS GOING UP THERE WAS
A STUDY THAT CAME OUT THAT
SHOWED THAT- HABITATS AND
WILDLIFE INSIDE MPAS- I WORK
WERE MORE RESISTANCE TO INVASIVE
SARGASSUM. COMPLIANCE IS ALSO
GETTING BETTER- WE'RE SEEING
MORE AND MORE FOLKS
UNDERSTANDING AND FOLLOWING THE
RULES. AND MPAS AS WELL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND A GOLF
GONZALEZ PASSED. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO- THAT SET A MINIMUM.
FINE FOR A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR VIOLATIONS AND WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THE IMPACT OF
THAT- THAT BLL IN TERMS. OF
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT AS
WELL. I THE QUESTION YOU'RE
SPECIFIC OF TRIBES SENATOR
LAYERED YOU KNOW I THINK WE ARE
THOSE OF US WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
AND PROBABLY THOSE WHO WARRANT
COULD AGREE THAT THE FACT THAT
THE MLK WAS SILENCE ON TRIBES. I
WAS A MAJOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
OVERSIGHTS I THINK THAT WE ALL
SEE THAT AND YOU KNOW. JACKIE
ARE COMMISSIONER HOUSE OF
COMMONS AND WAS WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN NAVIGATING THAT
SOCIAL JUSTICE OVERSIGHT AND
FINDING A WAY THROUGH- THAT WAS
THAT WAS RIGHT BY THE TRIBES.
ONE THING THOUGH THAT HAS THERE
BEEN MANYPOSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
TRIBES ACT I AS I SEE IT MORE I
SAID. THEY CAME OUT OF THE M. P.
AFTERWARDS AND ONE THING THAT I
THINK IS RELATED. TO YOUR
QUESTION CENTER LAYERED IS THE
TRIBAL MARINE STEWARDS NETWORK
PILOT PROGRAM- THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL JUST FUNDED A
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN ENVIRONMENTAL
PLANS TO SUPPORT THE DEVLOPMENT
OF THIS MARINE STEWARDS NETWORK
PILOT PROGRAM- THAT WILL ALLOW
TRIBES TO BUILD CAPACITY FOR
RESEARCH AND MONITORING OF
NPA'S. ENGAGEMENT WITH TRIBES
COLLECTING AND SHARING DATA AND
THEN FIGURING OUT HOW TO SCALE
THAT UP SO. I THINK- IN TERMS OF
THE COMMANDMENTS AND THE
DEFINITION OF SUBSISTENCE I
WOULD LEAVE THAT ANSWER TO
COMMISSIONER HOUSE APARTMENTS
AND IS THAT IT THE CHAIR OF THE
TRIBAL COMMITTEE. BUT IN TERMS
OF- TRIBAL ENGAGEMENTS ON MPA'S
MOVING FORWARD I'M JUST SO
DELIGHTED AND EXCITED TO SEE IF-
INDIGENOUS KNOWLEDGE
APPROPRIATELY AND THOUGHTFULLY
WOVEN INTO- OUR MPA NETWORK AND. AND THE MANAGEMENT- IMPIOUS.
THANK YOU I DOCTORS A LETTER.
THANK YOU- WE SHOULD BE
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S DONE WITH THE MTA
NETWORK IT'S A MODEL FOR THE
WORLD AND- I THINK THAT JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS
BEYOND THE MANY IMPORTANT POINTS
THAT MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS
HAVE RAISED- SO YOU KNOW NOT
ONLY AM I PROUD OF WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS A STATE AND ALL OF THE
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THAT THE
NPA'S AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
THEY'RE WORKING BUT WE'RE ALSO
COMMITTED TO THAT WE'RE GOING
FOR IT AND- I THINK THAT. FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF A SCIENTIST
YOU SCIENCE IS A PROCESS SO
WE'RE CONTINUALLY LEARNING NOT
ONLY ABOUT HOW THEY ARE WORKING
TO PROTECT INDIVIDUAL SPECIES
AND FISHERIES- BUT ALSO WHERE WE
CAN REFINE REGULATION AROUND THE
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS OVER TIME
AS WE LEARN ABOUT WHAT'S NEEDED-
I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW ON THE ON
THE SUBJECT OF TRIBES IT IS A
PRIORITY OF THE OF THE GOVERNOR
TO INCREASE TRAVEL ACCESS
SUBSISTENCE INCOME MANAGEMENT
ACROSS THE BOARD AND IT HAS BEEN
A WONDERFUL EDUCATION FOR ME TO.
PARTICIPATE WITH COMMISSIONER
HOSLER COMMONSENSE IN ALL OF THE
TRAVEL COMMITTEE MEETINGS THAT
HAVE TAKEN PLACE SINCE I JOINED
THE COMMISSION LAST YEAR- I CAN
SEE HUGE POTENTIAL FOR US AS A
COMMISSION. AROUND RAIN PROTECT
AREAS BUT ALSO MORE BROADLY TO
BE INCORPORATING INDIGENOUS
KNOWLEDGE. AND INCORPORATING
THOSE THOSE TRAVEL PARTNERS INTO
THE WORK THAT WE DO AND INTO THE
DECISION MAKING THAT WE DO- I
THINK. ONE OF THE FRONTIERS FOR
US WITH THE MPAS. SENATOR THERE
IT IS THAT SOMETHING WE
DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
THAT SOME OF THE SPECIES THAT
ARE BENEFITING FROM THEM- THE
SAM AND THE STEEL HEAD. THAT
DEPEND ON BOTH THE OCEAN AND THE
INLAND RIVERS ND STREAMS AND SO
ON IN CALIFORNIA- NEED HELP ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT LAND C.
INTERFACE IS NOWHERE ELSE IN THE
WORLD. ARE THE LAND AND SEA
CONNECTED AS THEY ARE IN
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY GOT MORE
THAN HERE- AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT IS ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE
CAN PUSH FOR IT WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDING HOW THOSE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THE OCEAN.
AND THE COAST- IMPACTS THE
ABILITY OF THOSE MPAS TO PROTECT
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WE
INTENDED THEM TO. THANKS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR THOSE
COMMENTS EACH OF YOU LET ME I
TURN NOW TO SENATOR KAMLAGER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU- TO THE THREE OF YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SERVICE I'M- APOLOGIES FOR
NOT BEING ABLE TO- MEET WITH YOU
BEFORE TODAY'S HEARING BUT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO READ THROUGH
THE MATERIALS. I AM. I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION AND EACH OF YOU-
CAN RESPOND YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
LOS ANGELES IT ISN'T URBAN
CENTER- THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
ACTUALLY- JUST RECENTLY IN THE
NEW YORK TIMES THAT TALKED
ABOUT. URBAN FISHING IN LOS
ANGELES- AND SPECIFICALLY THE
ACTIVITIES THAT FISHING
ACTIVITIES THAT HAPPEN. IN THE
L. A. RIVER- WHICH YOU KNOW
CURRENTLY THIS- WATER WAY IS
MORE REMINISCENT OF AN OVERSIZED
STORM DRAINS THAN A RIVER AND
YET EVEN WITH THAT- THERE IS
MARINELIFE HAPPENING AND- URBAN
FISHING HAPPENING- WHICH I THINK
IS GREAT. SO I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO KNOW. YOU KNOW HOW YOU WILL
EXPAND- OUT REACH AND INTEREST-
TO FOLKS IN URBAN COMMUNITIES
LIKE LOS ANGELES- AS IT RELATES
TO THE COMMISSION BECAUSE I
THINK OFTENTIMES WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THIS COMMISSION WERE
THINKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW RURAL
AREAS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SORT OF YOU
KNOW NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK THERE ARE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE WITH-
FOLKS IN URBAN CENTERS LIKE LOS
ANGELES ON THAT ARE MORE
CONCRETE THAN GREEN- AS IT
RELATES TO THE EFFORTS THAT YOU
ARE TRYING TO IMPACT. AND YOUR
MISSION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR LET ME A START IN THE
SAME ORDER- SO MISS HOSLER
HARMISON WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU SENATOR AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT COMES TO MIND IS THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
R. THREE AND THERE SHOULD HAVE
WHICH IS TO RECRUIT RETRAIN. AND
RE ACTIVATE- PARTICIPATION AND
ACCESS FOR HUNTING AND FISHING.
I THINK THAT IS JUST AN AMAZING
PROGRAM AND IT'S ALSO A
NATIONWIDE MOVEMENT FOCUSED ON
REVERSING THE DECLINE IN HUNTING
AND FISHING AND SHOOTING AND
SPORTS PARTICIPATION- SO
INTRODUCED. YOU AND EVEN ADULTS
WHO HAVE NOT HAD OPPORTUNITIES
TO HUNT AND FISH IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN. DIRECT THEM TO THAT
DEPARTMENT R. THREE INITIATIVES
AND I THINK YOU KNOW IT WAS THAT
IT STAKEHOLDERS FOCUSED ON.
THERE WERE AND EIGHT
STAKEHOLDERS- SUBCOMMITTEES AND
IT WAS ADULT ONSET REACTIVATION
AND HOUSTON FAMILIES MARKETING
AND PUBLIC PERCEPTION LICENSE
STRUCTURE ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
AND MENTORSHIP SO THAT
MENTORSHIP IS VERY KEY KEY
ELEMENTS BEGIN INTRODUCING.
FOLKS IN THE LA AREA THAT HAVE
NOT HAD THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO.
WE COME HERE AND GET OUT IN
WILDLIFE AND ENJOYING MAYBE
THROUGH A MENTORSHIP PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MR MURRAY. YES THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR SO
I WOULD ECHO COMMISSIONER HOUSE
APARTMENTS AND I ANSWER AND
MAYBE JUST ADD A COUPLE POINTS
TO IT YOU KNOW UNDER THE R.
THREE WHICH AGAIN IS RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AD REACTIVATION
EFFORT THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
LAUNCHED AND IS A PART OF A
NATIONWIDE EFFORT. THERE'S A
REALLY THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS OF
THESE OPPORTUNITY BARRIERS RIGHT
THAT WOULD THAT WE KNOW EXIST
EVEN IF WE DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND THEM RIGHT ACCESS TO
LAND AND WATER- MAYBE NOT HAVING
THE TECHNICAL EQUIPMENT TO GO
FISHING MAYBE NOT UNDERSTANDING
THE RULES OR HAVING THE TRAINING
OR KNOWLEDGE OF FISHING AND
HUNTING AS WELL AS THESE
INCLUSIVITY BARRIERS RIGHT NOT
EVERYBODY FEELS WELCOME IN THE
OUTDOORS AND EVERYBODY FEELS
WELCOME AND THAT THE SPORT OF
FISHING OR HUNTING THAT
EVERYBODY EVEN FEEL SAFE. DOING
THOSE SPORTS- AND THAT COULD BE
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS AND
SOME OF THOSE COULD BE CULTURAL
OR HISTORICAL TRAUMA- COULD BE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS OR A LACK OF
SIGNAGE SO THERE IS A AN ACTION
PLAN IN A WORK PLAN UNDER THIS
R. THREE- PACKAGE THAT YOU KNOW
TALKS ABOUT THINGS LIKE
EXPANDING FISHING IN THE CITY
PROGRAMS INCREASING STOCKING BY
10% IN URBAN PARKS AND COMMUNITY
IS- EXPANDING THIS FISHING
PASSPORT PROGRAM WHICH- IS SORT
OF A IT SAYS YOU'RE A HUNDRED
AND- FIFTY FISH AND THEN YOU CAN
BUT YOU CAN CATCH IN THE STATE
IN HERE ALL THE PLACES TO FIND
THEM AND YOU GET STAMPS- AND
YOU'RE ABLE TO YOU KNOW THERE'S
AN APP THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT. AND YOU KNOW THE R. THREE
EFFORT IN THE DEPARTMENT IS
REALLY LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT
FISHING PASSPORT EFFORT IN THE
OUT BY IT I THINK TWENTY 5% THIS
YEAR. JACKIE MAY. MENTORSHIP
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT- FOLKS ARE
NEW TO OUR NEW TO FISHING AND
HUNTING AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL. AND
THEN FINALLY I WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW THERE'S A BILL ABOUT-
RELATED TO THIS THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE- DATE FISHING
LICENSE THAT HAS. YOU KNOW IT
WAS IT TOOK A WHILE TO MAKE IT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE BUT
EVENTUALLY IT DID AND IT PASSED
SO NOW WHEN YOU BUY A FISHING
LICENSE FOR YOUR- FIFTY TWO
DOLLARS OR WHATEVER IT IS. IF
YOU BITE IN NOVEMBER IT DOESN'T
EXPIRE DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST IT
DIDN'T EXPIRES IN TWELVE MONTHS
SO YOU REALLY DO GET THAT THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS OF
FISHING. SOME UP AND RUNNING AND
WE'RE WORKING ON IT NOW OR
RATHER THE DEPARTMENT IS WORKING
ON THAT NOW. THAT'S GOING TO
ROLL OUT IN MID TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND I THIK THAT'S ALSO
REALLY VALUABLE FOR MAKING SURE
FOLKS FEEL LIKE. THEY INVEST IN
A FISHING LICENSE FEE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS.
SAID TO USE IT AND GET THEIR
MONEY'S WORTH AND I THINK THAT
THAT COULD BE A GOOD A GOOD-
GOOD WAY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT. THAT YOU
MENTIONED AS WELL SENATOR. THANK
YOU DOCTORS OF A LAUGH. YEAH
THANK YOU I THINK THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT
BECAUSE I WAS THAT URBAN KID WHO
LOVED WILDLIFE AND DIDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A LOT OF ACCESS
TO IT. I FEEL LIKE THERE ARE
THREE PARTS TO THIS ONE IS
GETTING WILDLIFE INTO URBAN
SPACES ANOTHER IS GETTING
ESPECIALLY YOUTH BUT ALSO THEIR
PARENTS ALSO ADULTS- OUT INTO
PLACES WHERE THEY CAN HUNT AND
FISH. AND THEN THE THIRD PIECE
OF THIS IS ACCESS TO DECISION
MAKING AND PARTICIPATION IN THIS
WHOLE PROCESS YEAH JUST. MAKING
IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY IN CITIES BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST URBAN
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT- THE NON URBAN
AREAS AREN'T IMPORTANT I THINK
IT JUST MEANS THAT. IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT WORK AND- MORE URGENT
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
SERVING THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
KEEPING THEM CONNECTED TO LAND
WATER AND WILDLIFE SO- I WAS
VERY VERY EXCITED TO SEE THE
ACTORS FOR ALL. AT NEWS THAT
THERE'S SO MUCH FUNDING GOING
INTO CREATING MORE GREEN SPACE
AND PARKS IN URBAN AREAS AND
PARTICULARLY WITH. REGARD TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
RECEIVING MORE OF THAT BENEFIT
AND THEY HAVE HISTORICALLY-
WILDLIFE FOLLOWS GREEN SPACE
INTO CITIES AND BASS AT. YOU
KNOW IT'S TRUE WHETHER WHAT
YOU'RE RESTORING IS THE L. A.
RIVER OR WHETHER IT'S NEW GREEN
SPACE- YOU KNOW FOR ATHLETIC
FIELDS AND SO ON. ANOTHER PIECE
OF THIS IS. WHAT COMMISSIONERATE
MENTIONED I WAS JUST READING
ABOUT STOCKING I THINK IT WAS OF
BROOK TROUT INTO- URBAN PONDS IN
SACRAMENTO THAT. WAS IN THE NEWS
THIS WEEK- THAT'S HAPPENING AND
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT. AND THEN WITH
RESPECT TO IT SO WE'RE BRINGING
WILDLIFE INTO THE CITY'S
OPPORTUNITIES INTO CITIES AND
THEN I THINK WE ALSO REALLY WANT
TO WORK TO SUPPORT MORE ACCESS
THROUGH EFFORTS LIKE OUR THREE-
RETREAT RETAIN REACTIVATE
PROGRAM. WHAT THAT OFTEN LOOKS
LIKE IS. ITS PARTNERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
IT IS COMMERCIAL FISHING BOAT
OPERATORS VOLUNTEERING THEIR
TIME AND RESOURCES TO TAKE A
GROUP OF KIDS OUT SO THAT THEY
CAN LEARN TO FISH IN THE OCEAN
AND THAT'S THE KIND OF
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU KNOW CAN
REALLY CHANGE THEIR LIVES AND-
GET THEM HOOKED FOR LIFE. THE
THIRD PIECE OF THAT IS ACCESS TO
DECISION MAKING AND THAT JUSTICE
EQUITY DIVERSITY INCLUSION PLAN.
THAT WHEN I JOIN THE COMMISSION
WAS SORT OF. GAINING STE. IS I
AM PROUD TO SAY OUR STAFF TO
SPEND MIRACULOUSLY- AT. AT
INCLUSIVE- AND EFFECTIVE AT
MOVING THAT FORWARD AND THAT
REALLY ADDRESSES BOTH ACCESS TO
NATURE AND ACCESS TO THIS WHOLE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN WHEN WE
WENT REMOTE BUT OUR COMMISSION
MEETINGS IS THAT WE REALIZED
THAT MADE IT A LOT EASIER FOR
MANY MORE PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A TO TRAVEL AND TAKE TIME OFF
OF WORK. SO I THINK THAT'S JUST
ONE OTHER WAY THAT WE ARE REALLY
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
HUNTING AND FISHING AND ALL OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES TO ACCESS
WILDLIFE FOR AVAILABLE TO MY
FOLKS PARTICULARLY IN CITIES.
YES THANK YOU I'M CERTAINLY- YOU
KNOW. WE HAVE THE GLENMORE LAKE
ACTUALLY I CAN HAVE PARK IN LOS
ANGELES AND THEY STOCK THAT
QUITE REGULARLY IT IS A COUNTY
PARK BUT JUST TO SEE THEIR
FAMILIES COMMON. LEARN HOW TO
FISH AND YOU SEE PARENTS
SPENDING TIME WITH CHILDREN AND
GRANDPARENTS SPENDING TIME WITH
THEIR GRANDCHILDREN- YOU KNOW
PROBABLY- TAKING PART IN THE
TRADITION OF FAMILY TRADITION. I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT. AND
IT'S THE CONNECTIVE TISSUE. THAT
I THINK WE SHOULD BE-
SUPPORTING. AS WERE CONNECTING
FOLKS TO NATURE AND- YOU KNOW
ACTIVITIES THAT ALLOW YOU TO BE
OUTSIDE. EXTRATERRESTRIAL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSES TO THOSE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR- IT
WHAT A WHAT A LIVELY DISCUSSION
IN TERMS OF SOME THINGS THAT I
AM LEARNING I WISH WE COULD
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO WITH URBAN
COYOTES IN PARKS BUT I'LL I WILL
I WILL GO THERE I WILL AT LEAST
NOT RIGHT NOW I WILL TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE WHO IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY OF VICE CHAIR BATES AND
THEN OF COURSE TO SENATOR GROW
SO- VICE CHAIR ARE YOU. THEYARE
PREPARED TO ASK COMMENTS OR MAKE
OUR MAKE COMMENTS OR ASK
QUESTIONS I'M JUST GOING TO MAKE
COMMENTS BECAUSE I BELIEVE THIS
THIS SUB PANEL ARE PROBABLY HAVE
GIVEN THE MOST IN DEPTH
RESPONSES TO ALL THE QUESTIONS
THAT CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN ON OUR
REVIEW SHEETS AND A VERY VERY
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT THAT-
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS ARE DOING
WELL BECAUSE I HAVE A COASTAL
DISTRICT AS YOU KNOW AND IT WAS
A VERY VERY HOT TOPIC US SEVERAL
YEARS AGO. AND A LOT OF BY A LOT
OF BY A ROUND TABLES AND-
CITIZEN NO GROUPS AND FISHERMEN
IN SEOUL- THOSE WHO HAVE OTHER
COMMERCIAL FISHING BOATS AND
CERTAINLY THOSE WHO HAVE
COMMERCIAL PASSENGER FISHING
BOATS ALL OF THAT WAS ON. THERE
WAS A LOT OF THREATS ABOUT IT A
LOT OF WORRY ABOUT THAT AND IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THINGS THAT
REALLY HAVE FALLEN INTO PLACE
AND ALL ASPECTS ABOUT ARE REALLY
WORKING FULL THANK YOU ALL FOR A
VERY IN DEPTH DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT AND CERTAINLY I STANDING UP
DURING THAT TIME TO CREATE THOSE
IT WAS I KNOW IT'S NOT AN EASY
ASSIGNMENT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE OF
THE BEST OF WHAT WE HOPE FOR IS
COMING TO THE FORE IN THAT'S
GOING TO. BENEFIT EVERYBODY ALSO
ON NOW I NOTICED A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE I'M A LITTLE SAD ABOUT
THE COMMERCIAL PASSENGER FISHING
BOATS HAVING ACCESS FOR ALL
THOSE WHO NEVER FISH THE OCEAN
BEFORE- HOURS YOU PEOPLE LIVE IN
THE URBAN CENTER SIDE THAT'S
REALLY. GREAT TO HEAR FROM YOU
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THAT'S ANOTHER
VERY CONTROVERSIAL AREA. IN
TERMS OF THOSE PARTICULAR-
PASSENGER FISHING BOATS THAT ARE
UP AGAINST. SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
THEY NEED TO MAKE WITH. THE
ADMISSIONS. AND CLIMB CHANGE IN
ALL THAT SO KNOWING THAT WE HAVE
A FIVE OF THAT REALLY ONE TO
RETURN. OUR TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ENJOYING. OF BEING
ON THE OCEAN AND WITH THEIR
FISHING POLES IN THE OCEAN. AND
ENJOYING ON THAT BILLS CREATURES
OUT THERE IN THE IN THE BEST OF
ALL POSSIBLE WAYS YOU KNOW THEY
DO A LOT OF B. R. WELL WATCHING
IT YOU KNOW AND- WATCH THE-
CORPUS- MIGRATION THE WILL
MIGRATION ENOUGH THE PURPOSE IS
ALL ABOUT AND IT'S ALL. POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE CERTAINLY ON WITH THE
MANY OF YOU INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES SO. I IDEA AND I
WANT TO ASK BUT I THINK YOU DID
ANSWER. ARE HOW ARE YOU YOU
WANTED TO- IN WRITTEN RESPONSES
THE IMPORTANCE OF WORKING TO GET
MORE STAKEHOLDERS. ARE INVOLVED-
AND I THINK THAT YOU COVERED
THAT VERY WELL IN A VARIETY OF
YOUR COMMENTS SO. YOU WILL HAVE
MY SUPPORT- YOU CERTAINLY HAVE
MY- GRATITUDE FOR YOUR WILLING
TO SERVE BECAUSE I KNOW SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE-
CONFRONTED WITH SOME. THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY AND COLLECTIVELY-
ARE NOT ALWAYS EASY TO EXPLAIN
OF WHAT THE LONG TERM GOAL IS
AND YOU'VE DONE THAT VERY WELL
SO. THANK YOU ALL AND- LOOK
FOWARD TO- NEEDS THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND THEN. ON TO THE
BALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VICE-
SENATOR GROW. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM. THANK YOU AND I DO ECHO
MY COLLEAGUES S. COMMENTS THAT
YOU GUYS DID PRIZEFIGHT SUCH AN
EXTENSIVE RESPONSE TO ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED AND
THAT MAKES OUR JOBS I THINK A
LOT EASIER WHEN IT'S IN WRITING
AND WE CAN GET SOME INFORMATION
AND A HEAD OF TIME AND SO I DO
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THOUGH.
AND I DON'T MIND IF WE CONTINUE
IN THE SAME ORDER THAT WE TOOK
THE PREVIOUS QUESTIONS I'LL ASK
THE ONE QUESTION EACH OF YOU CAN
ANSWER I HAVE THREE QUESTIONS
I'M THE FIRST ONE IS WHEN
SETTING HUNTING AND FISHING
REGULATIONS HOW DO YOU. WAIT
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AGAINST
AND ONE IS A NON SCIENTIFIC
PUBLIC IMPACT ON YOUR DECISION
MAKING PROCESS BECAUSE I KNOW
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT DON'T WANT S. YOU
KNOW INVADING ANIMAL HABITATS I
GUESS I'M IS THE BEST WAY TO
EXPLAIN IT. SO HOW DO YOU WEIGH
AND THE DECISIONS YOU MAKE ON
HUNTING AND FISHING REGULATIONS
BASED ON SCIENCE AND NOT. AND
WHAT COMES IN FROM NON
SCIENTIFIC PUBLIC MEMBERS IF
THAT MAKES SENSE. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO I JACKAL HOSTILE
HARMISON'S FIRST. I THANK YOU
SENATOR GROWTH FOR THE QUESTION
NO- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME TO
LOOK AT THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE TO INCORPORATE ANY ANY
INFORMATION- ALSO TRADITIONAL
ECOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE FROM THE
FROM THE TRIBES OF THE CULTURAL
LEADERS. BUT I REALLY ALSO LOOK
AT CITIZEN SCIENCE- YOU KNOW OUR
FISHERMEN OUT HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE THE VERY BEST
EFFORTS OUT THERE ON THE WATER
AS TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AND THEY
IN FACT TO GET INVOLVED AND
COLLECT DATA FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AT TIMES SO FOR ME IT'S A
ROBUST. OVERVIEW OF ALL ALL.
PEOPLE ALSO ITEMS. THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SCIENCE AND THEN COMING
UP WITH WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
RESOURCE WHAT IS BEST FOR THAT-
SPECIES. SO IT IS IT'S A MULTI
FACETED DECISION WITH LOTS OF
RESEARCH AND- TAKING THAT THE
PUBLIC INPUT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT A LOT OF TIMES WE
RECEIVED GREAT INFORMATION THE
DAY OF THE MEETING ON THAT ITEM.
SO THOSE THOSE ARE THE WAYS I'D
I'D BALLOTS IT AND TRY TO MAKE
THE BEST AVAILABLE DECISION WITH
SCIENCE BEING THAT THE
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU- MISS
MARIE. YES THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR- I WISH THAT I
HAD A SORT OF COOKIE CUTTER
RESPONSE THAT WE APPLY IN EVERY
CASE BUT IT FOR ME I'S NOT LIKE
THAT RIGHT ITS CASE BY CASE WE
TAKE THE SCIENCE ARE THERE ARE
DECISIONS ARE DRIVEN BY SCIENCE
AND THEY MUST ABSOLUTELY BE
INFORMED BY SCIENCE. AND WE ALSO
CARE ABOUT COMMUNITY IS RIGHT
ESPECIALLY AS W ARE BUILDING
OUT THIS JUSTICE EQUITY
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION. I WORK
PLAN AND POLICY AND ENVISION- WE
YOU KNOW I DON'T I'LL SPEAK FOR
ME PERSONALLY IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO REALLY. EARNESTLY
BALANCE ARE DUAL
RESPONSIBILITIES OF A HEALTHY
BIODIVERSE AND NATURAL
CALIFORNIA WHERE NATIVE FISH AND
WILDLIFE THRIVE IN DYNAMIC
ECOSYSTEMS WHILE ALSO INSPIRING
HUMAN INTERACTION AND ENJOYMENT
AND THAT INCLUDES NON
CONSUMPTIVE AND CONSUMPTIVE
RECREATION SO THOSE ARE TWO- TWO
GOALSTHAT WE HAVE THAT THAT DO
NOT ALWAYS SQUARE RIGHT AND SO
IT IS NOT ALWAYS EASY TO TAKE
THE SCIENCE AND ACHIEVE THOSE
TWO GOALS AND- THE WAY THAT WE
DO IT IS WE READ THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS YOU KNOW OUR BINDERS
ARE SOMETIMES TWO THOUSAND PAGES
GOING INTO A MEETING AND A LOT
OF THAT IS IT'S STAFF MEMBERS
BUT IT'S ALSO. SCIENTIFIC PAPERS
AND A LOT OF IT IS PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND WE READ THOSE
COMMENTS WE LISTEN- DURING
MEETINGS I HAVE SEEN YOU KNOW
TIMES WHERE WE AS A COMMISSION
ARE ALL AGAIN SPEAK FOR MYSELF I
GO INTO A MEETING THINKING MAYBE
THERE'S GOING TO BE ONE OUTCOME
AND THEN AFTER HEARING WHAT
EVERYBODY SAYS IT'S A DIFFERENT
OUTCOME- THE OTHER THING I'LL
SAY IS WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
COMPLETE DATA SETS RIGHT WE
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE ALL THE DATA
THAT WE WISH THAT WE HAD. AND WE
STILL NEED TO MAKE ART YOU KNOW
A DECISION BASED ON THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE THAT WE DO
HAVE AND THE INTERESTS OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND THESE TWO
IMPORTANT GOALS THAT WE HAVE-
SOMETIMES WE GET LUCKY FOR
EXAMPLE A COUPLE OF WITHIN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS THERE WAS A
PACIFIC HERRING FISHERY
MANAGEMENT PLAN WERE
STAKEHOLDERS BOTH FISHERMEN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS GOT TOGETHER AND
SORT OF. CREATED A DRAFT AT THEM
HE LARGELY FOR US RIGHT THAT'S
WHEN WE GOT REALLY LUCKY AND
WERE ABLE TO GET SOMETHING THAT
THEY WORKED ON TOGETHER AND WE
CAN APPROVE IT UNANIMOUSLY AND
THEY DO SOME OF THAT WORK FOR US
AND I DO THINK WE SEE THAT MORE
AND MORE I THINK THE WAY THAT
NATURAL RESOURCES POLICY AND
MANAGEMENT IS UNDERTAKEN HAS
CHANGED A LOT JUST IN THE TWENTY
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IT. AND SO WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE
GET VERY LUCKY- WHEN OF DOZENS
KNOW WE'VE DO THE THAT WE CAN
TAKE IN THE SCIENCE. TWO GOALS
AND LISTENING TO THE FOLKS WHO
COME IN AND TALK TO US. THANK
YOU DOCTORS A LOT OF A LOT OF
SORRY. THANKS WELL I'M A
SCIENTIST SO I LIKE SCIENCE AS I
THINK EVIDENCE AS YOU KNOW IT.
IT'S NECESSARY BUT IT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT FOR OUR DECISIONS TO
BE SUPPORTED BY EVIDENCE FOR
MANY OF THE REASONS THAT
MISSIONARY JUST RAISED- I THINK
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SOMETIMES CAN
CAN LAY SIDE OF IS THAT THE WAY
THAT HUNTING AND FISHING OR
SUSTAINS NOW IS THAT. YOU KNOW
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SCIENCE
BASED MODERN MANAGEMENT AND
THAT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT PART OF
WHAT WE DO WITH THE COMMISSION
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. SO OF COURSE THE
SCIENCE IS VERY IMPORTANT THE
OTHER PIECE OF THAT IS THAT OUR
DECISIONS BE SOCIALLY ACCEPTABLE
AND SOCIALLY- SUPPORTED. BUT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
THAT TO MISSION. AS A COMMISSION
SO WE HAVE THIS DEAL MISSION TO
PROMOTE INTO REGULATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENJOY. THOSE
INCLUDE HUNTING AND FISHING- AND
TO PROTECT NATIVE WILDLIFE AND
IN THE LONG RUN IT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
MAYBE AND- AT. JUST ARTICULATED
I THINK IN THE LONG TERM
PROTECTING WILDLIFE REQUIRES
SUSTAINING PEOPLE'S
RELATIONSHIPS TO IT SO. THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE ALWAYS
INCLUDED HUNTING AND FISHING
SOMETIMES WHEN WE HAVE
INCOMPLETE INFORMATION WE HAVE
TO WEIGH. THE RISKS AND THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND AT ALLOWING
HARDEST AGAINST THE RISKS AND
UNCERTAINTY AROUND SEVERING
PEOPLE'S RELATIONSHIP TO THE
WILDLIFE THAT THEY HUNT AND FISH
SO WE ALWAYS A BALANCING ACT
THERE BUT I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT
I WOULD COME BACK TO IS THAT-
HUNTING AND FISHING ARE. CORE
PARTS OF WHAT WE SUPPORT AS ACT
AS A COMMISSION AND SO THOSE TWO
PIECES OF OUR MISSION GO
TOGETHER WE NEED HEALTHY
WILDLIFE POPULATIONS TO SUSTAIN
US HUNTING AND FISHING
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE NEED
HUNTING AND FISHING TO SUSTAIN
PEOPLE'S CONNECTIONS TO WILDLIFE
. THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH AND THE NEXT QUESTION I
HAVE IS IN YOUR OPINION SHOULD
THE COMMISSION'S REGULATORY
PROCESSES SUPPORT GREATER
FISHING AND HUNTING
OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS- INCREASED
A BAG LIMITS TAGS AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS IF THE SCIENCE
IS THERE TO. AND SUPPORT IT.
MYTHOS LEARN KARMA FINALLY JUST
GO AHEAD AND START WITH YOU
AGAIN WILL KEEP GOING IN THIS
ORDER. YOU'RE DOING WELL AT IT
YOU'RE DOING SO WELL I DON'T
NEED TO. SAY ANYTHING. YOU KNOW-
SENATOR GROSS I REALLY BELIEVE.
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS
YES I THINK THE COMMISSION
SHOULD SUPPORT- INCREASED BAG
LIMIT. ON INCREASED OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR HUNTING AND ANGLING
COMMUNITIES VERY DEFINITELY-
EVERY EVERY DAY IN IN MY NORMAL
DAY TO DAY JOB. I COME INTO
CONTACT WITH FOLKS WHO DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE REGULATION THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY CAN'T
GO OUT. AND FISH DURING CERTAIN
TIMES OR WHY THE HELL OF IT
SEASON HAS BEEN. CUT OFF IN
AUGUST WHEN NORMALLY IN THE PAST
AND IT WAS IN OCTOBER SO I
ANSWERED THOSE QUESTIONS ON A
DAILY BASIS AND I THINK WHEN THE
SCIENCE ALLOWS. ABSOLUTELY WE
SHOULD BE. PROVIDING ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY- IF IT IS NOT THAT
RISKS TO THE SPECIES I THINK
THAT ECOSYSTEM BASED MANAGEMENT
IS IMPERATIVE. BUT ALSO THE
REGARD. FOR THE HUMAN CONNECTION
. THANK YOU MMHM. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION YOU
KNOW FOR ME IT I SAID THIS IS A
VERY LAWYER ANSWERED TO GIVE BUT
I AM A LAWYER SO I HAD. PLANS
RIGHT IT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON
THE SPECIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO ANSWER THAT JUST ACROSS THE
BOARD YES ALL THE TIME YOU KNOW
HIGHER BAG LIMITS MORE TAKE ON
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ARE YOU KNOW
IT IS I COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH
WHAT- COMMISSIONERS OF A LOT OF
SAD ABOUT THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN- YOU KNOW ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY AND HOW THAT DOES
FOSTER STEWARDSHIP. AND LONG
TERM CONSERVATION AND THE INTER
RELATEDNESS OF THOSE TWO THINGS
YOU KNOW IF WE DO NOT MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THRIVING WILDLIFE
AND ECOSYSTEMS INTO THE INTO THE
FUTURE AND THEN WE NO LONGER
HAVE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO HUNT
AND FISH FOR THE SPECIES SO THEY
ARE VERY MUCH INTER RELATED- I
THINK IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE INCREASING DROUGHTS
INCREASING WILDFIRES AND JUST
THAT SORT OF SO MANY CHANGING
SYSTEMS ALL THE TIME. I CAN SAY
THAT I'M COMMITTED TO PRESERVING
AND ENHANCING OPPORTUNITIES
WHEREVER POSSIBLE AND AT THE
SAME TIME IT'S GOING TO BE A
CASE BY CASE BASIS AND IT'S VERY
TRICKY TO JUST GIVE UP A BLANKET
APPLICATION OF SAYING IT'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE APPROPRIATE I
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE AS MANY HUNTERS AS WE
DID IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES AND IT'S A CHALLENGE
AND YOU KNOW THE R. THREE
EFFORTS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE ARE REALLY AT FINDING
WAYS TO ENGAGE NEW AUDIENCES
INCLUDING YOUNG PEOPLE. IN
HUNTING AND FISHING ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE I REALLY D BELIEVE
SOMEBODY WHO GREW UP FISHING YOU
KNOW I SAID IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS I GREW UP FISHING I'M
THE SON OF A OF A OF A VERY
COMMITTED HUNTER- AND I WAS JUST
A YOU KNOW IT'S VERY MUCH WHY I
DO WHAT I DO TODAY SO I SEE AND
I VALUE THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
AND GETTING OUTSIDE HUNTING
FISHING CONNECTING WITH THESE
RESOURCES AND WANTING TO PROTECT
THEM INTO THE FUTURE- AND SO. I
AM. WANT THEIR CREATE ENHANCE
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE WE CAN.
THANK YOU. DOCTORS OF A LETTER.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
QUESTION SENATOR GROVE- I THINK
THERE'S A LOT PACKED INTO THAT
IF THE SCIENCE SUPPORTS IT
RIGHT- A LOT THERE THAT DEPENDS
ON THE SPECIES ON THE CONTEXT ON
THE DIFFERENT CHALLENGES FACING
POPULATIONS BUT IF THE SCIENCE
SUPPORTS IT YES I THINK THAT
THAT'S PART OF OUR MISSION AND
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAN EVER PART OF OUR
GOAL IS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HUNTING AND FISHING
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE CAN'T
REALLY DO THAT IF WE DON'T
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES SO- IF
THE SCIENCE SUPPORTS THAT. AND
YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE ISN'T ANY
SORT OF HARM ANY RISK AND IN
MOVING FORWARD I THINK THE
ANSWER IS YES I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT- LAST WEEK I FACILITATED A
COMMISSION WORKSHOP- ON BIG GAME
HUNTING AND I WAS. I WAS
DELIGHTED BY THE TURN OUT
THERE'S A HUGE TURNOUT FROM
ACROSS THE STTE AND- I THINK
WHAT I WAS STRUCK BY THAT I
LEARNED SO MUCH FROM THEM AND IT
WASN'T JUST ABOUT PEOPLE'S VIEWS
IT WAS ALSO THERE ON THE GROUND
OBSERVATIONS AND KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
THE STATE OF OUR WILDLIFE AND-
IN LANDS AND I THINK WE HAVE A
LOT OF PARTNERS WE THINKING HARD
AND CRITICALLY ABOUT HOW TO
INCREASE OPPORTUNITY FOR SHIFT
OPPORTUNITY- YOU KNOW IN THE
NAME OF NOT JUST MORE ACCESSIBLE
MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS SO WE HAVE
A LOT OF PROGRESS THERE WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO THERE. THANK
YOU AND MY LAST QUESTIONS YOU
PLEASE ONE THE FIRST PART OF IT
OR THE SECOND PART WILL JUST BE
YES OR NO. I'M JUST CURIOUS AND-
AND THEN THE FIRST PART IS AND-
I HAVE A LAKE LIKE IS A BALLET
IT'S A SMALL COMMUNITY UP IN THE
MOUNTAIN AREA. IN MY DISTRICT
ACTUALLY AND IT RELIES ON
FISHING GAME STOCKING UP LIKE IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE TOURISM. FOR
THE TOWN TO SURVIVE AND- THE
LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS. THERE'S
BEEN A DECREASE IN STOCKING WHO
MAKES THE DECISION. ON WHAT KIND
OF FISHER HOW FISH GET STOCKED
IN DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE.
AND IS THAT THE COMMISSION. AND
CAN I REACH OUT TO SOMEBODY
ABOUT STOCKING THAT OR FIGURING
OUT WHY THEY'RE ON THE BOTTOM OF
THE LIST VERSUS THE MIDDLE ARE
TAUGHT. THAT'S THE FIRST
QUESTION I HAVE LIKE WHO MAKES
THAT DECISION I WASN'T SURE IF
IT WAS YOU GUYS OR- IT WAS THE
COMMISSION FROM IS SOMEBODY ELSE
IN THERE NOW AND- THE SECOND
QUESTION JUST YES OR NO DO ANY
OF YOU GUYS. ARE ALL OF YOU GUYS
ARE ANY OF YOU HAD A AND DINNER
FISHING LICENSE. THANK YOU ARE.
START AGAIN AT THE TOP WITH-
WITH JACQUELYN HOSLER COMMERCE
ON AND GO DOWN THE LIST AND-
THERE WERE TWO QUESTIONS I DON'T
KNOW THAT. EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
ANSWER THE FIRST ONE BUT SHE
CLEARLY WANTS AN ANSWER TO THAT
YESTERDAY. HE GO. I BELIEVE USED
REACH OUT TO DIRECTOR CHUCK
BONHAM. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND HIS- ONE
OF HIS CHIEF WILL WILL BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION I
BELIEVE THEY DO LOOK AT NEEDS
THEY THEY OOK AT. THE RESOURCES
THEY HAVE ON HAND AND I THINK
THEY THEY DO YOU HAVE A FORMULA
TO DETERMINE I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT FORMULA IS. OKAY INDIA
FISHING LICENSE I HAVE A
QUESTION LICENSE. AND IF I COULD
CIRCLE BACK I WANT TO STAY UP A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT. THE- THE
YES OR NO ANSWER ON SHOULD WE-
VIBE MORE OPPORTUNITY IF THE
SCIENCE SUPPORTS IT ONE THING
THAT I WANTED TO MAKE A POINT
ABOUT IS TRIBAL PEOPLE IN THEIR
IN THEIR LIFETIMES HAVE DONE
MANAGEMENT. THROUGH KNOWING WHEN
TO TAKE AND WHEN NOT TO CHECK
THEY HAVE BEEN THE GREATEST
RESOURCE MANAGERS OF ANY PEOPLE
AND FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS IN
HERE SO I BELIEVE LOOKING AT
THAT TRADITIONAL SCIENCE AND
GETTING THAT TRIBAL INPUT ON
THAT SPECIES AND IF THE
OPPORTUNITY EXISTENCE REALLY
IMPORTANT SO I JUST WANTED TO
CIRCLE BACK TO THAT. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU. MISS MERRY YES
I DO HAVE A FISHING LICENSE I DO
NOT HAVE A HUNTING LICENSE BUT I
HAVE- STARTED THE HUNTER
EDUCATION CLASS ONLINE IT'S ALL
DONE ONLINE RIGHT NOW AND IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT RIGHT NOW NOT
PRESENTLY DURING THIS HEARING
BUT I AM IN THE MIDDLE OF IT- I
RECENTLY AT MY DAD PASSED AWAY
MANY YEARS AGO BUT HE DID LEAVE
BEHIND- SOME TWELVE GAUGE SHOT
GUNS AND RIFLES AND I RECENTLY
YOU KNOW HAVE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACQUIRE SOME OF THOSE AND I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE IDEA OF
GOING OUT AND CARRYING ON A
TRADITION- OF HIS AND OF YOU
KNOW WHERE I'M FROM TO BE ABLE
TO GO- AND- DO SOME SOME HUNTING
AND COMMISSIONER. AND SKLAR AND
I HAVE BEEN HATCHING A PLAN TO
GET OUT TOGETHER HE YOU MAY KNOW
THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF- PHEASANT
AND DUCK HUNTING I THINK AS WELL
AS- YEAH. WE'VE BEEN HAVING A TO
GET OUT TOGETHER AND DO SOME
HUNTING SO. THAT IS THAT IS ONE
OF MY TWENTY TWENTY TWO CALLS.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY ABOUT YOUR
DEATH. THANK YOU. FOR DOCTORS OF
A LETTER IN HERE- I DON'T HAVE A
HUNTING LICENSE I HAVE TAKEN
CALIFORNIA CENTER EDUCATION
CLASS- AND THAT YOU KNOW KIND OF
WITHOUT GOING INTO ALL THE
DETAILS I WILL JUST SAY THAT IS
VERY MUCH ON MY BUCKET LIST FOR
THIS YEAR AND THE PANDEMIC
ACTUALLY FOR ME DELAYED. MY
ABILITY TO GO DOWN THERE AND I
HAVE A FISHING LICENSE AND- AND
ACTUALLY OUT TRYING TO CALM MY
NERVES FISHING THIS MORNING SO.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL. I'M THAT WAY
. LOS YOU GUYS THANK YOU FOR IN
MY MAKE ONCE. JUST ON THE BASIC
BUT I DO APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF
YOU I AM REACHING BOTH SIDES
REACHING THE PEOPLE THAT BRING
YOU KNOW REACHING AND PEOPLE
THAT IN URBAN AREAS THEY DON'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR FREE IN
SPACE AND THEN ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT OUR HUNTERS ANGLERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE THEIR
SUPPORT AND THEIR SKILL AND
THEN. YOU KNOW THEY FLY FRIED
FISH RIGHT SO AND KEEP INTERESTS
ARE AND ON THE SPECIES ACTUALLY
STOPPED EATING GAPES AND THAT
ALL YOU DO FOR THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE AS WELL AND THAT THAT
POPULATION OF OUR TRIBAL NATIONS
SO THANK YOU. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING YOUR NOMINATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW- WELL AS
IT IS ALL THE CASE WHEN YOU GO
LAST THERE'S VERY. LITTLE LEFT
TO COVER ALTHOUGH I'M SURE THIS
IS SUCH AN EXPANSIVE- TOPIC OF
ITEMS I COULD COME UP WITH
SOMETHING. I HOPE I'M NOT GONNA
BE OFFENSIVE WHEN I SAY. THIS
DOES NOT LOOK LIKE OUR
GRANDFATHERS FISH AND GAME%
COMMISSION I HAVE TO SAY AND I
MEAN THAT WITH. GREAT RESPECT
AND- PLEASURE ACTUALLY. I WAS
GOING TO COMMENT ON WHAT- MISS
HOSLER CONVERSE ON SANDWICHES.
AS I HEARD SOMEONE TALK ABOUT
SCIENCE BASED MODERN MANAGEMENT-
BUT SOCIALLY SUPPORTED I
ACTUALLY WAS THINKING BOY. I
THINK THEY'VE BEEN- GENERATIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT KNEW HOW TO DO
THIS WITHOUT. THE MODERN DAY
SCIENCE THAT WE SEEM TO TALK
ABOUT SO I WHEN I WANT TO GIVE
CREDENCE TO THAT- LIKE MS MURRAY
I GREW UP IN A RURAL COMMUNITY
IN SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA. I
SOUTHWESTERN VIRGINIA NOT WEST
VIRGINIA- BUT I- YOU KNOW WHO
GREW UP IN A FAMILY OF HUNTERS
AND FISSURES AND MY BROTHER WHO
LIVES IN NEW ENGLAND STILL DOES
HAUNT FOR FOOD FOR HIS FAMILY
AND- SO I HAVE AN APPRECIATION
BUT I GUARANTEE YOU- SENATOR ROB
I DO NOT HAVE A FISHING LICENSE.
I HAVE STRAYED A BIT FOR MY
ROOTS BUT I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- THE DIVERSITY AND
THE IMPORTANCE AND THE
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE. OF WHAT
WE'RE UP AGAINST IN MODERN DAY
CALIFORNIA LOOKING AT
REGULATIONS RULES AND- AND HOW
WE ADDRESS OUR DIVERSE
POPULATIONS. WITHIN YOU KNOW I
HAVE A REAL SIMPLE QUESTION IT'S
NOT A YES OR NO HUNTING FISHING
LICENSE QUESTION ALTHOUGH I DO
LIKE TO KNOW THOSE THINGS. I CAN
ALWAYS COUNT SENATOR GROVE TO
GET RIGHT TO THE HEART OF
SOMETHING. IMPORTANT YET
SEEMINGLY SIMPLE. IT IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW THE WHOLE. JERRY PLAN
AND- YOU KNOW THE FOCUS AND THE
DISCUSSION THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US
TODAY WHICH I SO APPRECIATE I
PULLED OUT SOME REAL GEMS FROM
THE CONVERSATION EACH OF YOU
ADDED TO. WHAT ARE REALLY THE
BEST WAYS TO ENGAGE CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE POPULATIONS THE HEARINGS
AND- DOCTORS OF A LETTER
MENTIONED THE FORM THAT SHE GOT
TO OVERSEE AND HOW PLEASED SHE
WAS TO SEE THE- THE EX THE LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE FROM UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. WHAT DO YOU SEE
THAT YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS CONVERSATION- S. AS
THE MEANS TO REALLY ENGAGE AS
YOU CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AS
THINGS CHANGE WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
YOU KNOW THE BALANCE BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW- SPECIES POPULATIONS
MAKING SURE THERE ARE THERE'S
THE BALANCE BETWEEN. ACCESS TO
HUNT OR FISH AND THE POPULATION
SO HOW DO WE ENGAGE JUST A
SIMPLE THING. FROM EACH OF YOU
ARE ARE NOT EVERYONE HAS TO
ANSWER BUT I JUST THINK THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
CHALLENGE AND I AM IMPRESSED
WITH EACH OF YOUR- RESUMES IN
YOUR BACKGROUND AND WHAT
DIFFERENT. PERSPECTIVE YOU EACH
BRING YET WHEN YOU ALL SPOKE.
YOU REALLY CREATED- QUITE A
MOSAIC OF WHAT WE'RE- DEALING
WITH IN CALIFORNIA IN A
CHANGING. CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS
OF IRVINE VERSUS WORLD SO. ON
MYTHOS WE'RE GOOD KARMA SOME YOU
WANT TO START AND ADD ANYTHING.
THERE ARE YOU KNOW THOSE WHERE I
BEGAN EIGHT YEARS AGO I WAS
TRYING TO DETERMINE HOW TO GET
TRIBES TO THE TABLE BECAUSE MY
FAMILY ARE NATIVE AMERICAN I WAS
VERY SENSITIVE TO THATAND I.
SAW EARLY ON THAT THERE WAS NO
WAY FOR THEIR VOICES TO BE
HEARD. AND SO. WERE IN ONE OF
THE EARLY MEETINGS I HAD A
TRIBAL LEADER CATCH ME IN THE
HALLWAY AND SAID WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO.
GET THE FOR THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION OR THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
THESE ISSUES ON ABALONE. SO I
WAS ABLE TO DURING THAT MEETING-
TALK TO THE AT THAT TIME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SONG CAME OUT
STRONG. AND I SENT SOME CAN JUST
PERSON REALLY NEEDS SOME HELP
REALLY NEEDS SOME TIME. AND I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIM IN THE
ROOM AND MAKE HIM FEEL
COMFORTABLE SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT IS. THERE IS
CREATING THE SPACE CREATING THE
FORUM LISTENING AND YOU KNOW A
LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE ARE
INTIMIDATED BY THE RULES AND THE
REGULATIONS THERE AND- IT IS- BY
THE PROCESS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RULE MAKING CALENDAR. IT'S
AMAZING IT'S VERY CONFUSING AT
TIMES SO I THINK HAVING THOSE.
WORKSHOPS THOSE WEBINARS THOSE
IN PERSON MEETINGS- THE
COMMISSION IS WORKING ON.
FISHING OUT. OTHERSSO MANY
GREAT WAY JUST IN THE LAST YEAR
THAT WE'VE EXPANDED THAT AND
THROUGH OUR STRATEGIC PLANNING
WE NEED TO DO MORE SO I THINK
THOSE PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS ONE
ON ONE. BRINGING THEM INTO THE
MEETING PROCESS AND THEN DOING A
FOLLOW UPS AFTERWARDS IS WHAT I
WOULD RECOMMEND. THANK YOU MISS
MARIE. YES THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- SO I THINK IN TERMS OF
ACCESS AND RELATIONSHIPS AND HOW
DO WE GET FOLKS INVOLVED IN OUR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS. YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE ARE THE FOLKS
WHO ARE ALREADY AWARE OF US AND
THEN THERE ARE THERE ARE FOLKS
WHO ARE NOT WHO MAYBE HAVE NEVER
HEARD OF US RIGHT IT SEEMS. NOW
HAVING GONE TO. A DECADE EVERY
MONTH A FISHING GAME COMMISSION
MEETINGS BEFORE EVER WAS ON THE
COMMISSION IT SEEMS YOU KNOW
UNBELIEVABLE TO THINK THAT WE
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE AN OBSCURE
BODY TO SOME FOLKS BUT NOT
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT WE DO.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE SO FOR
THE FOLKS WHO ALREADY ARE AWARE
OF US- HAVING THE MEETINGS HAS
ABSOLUTELY ENHANCED ACCESS TO
OUR PROCESS AND OUR DECISION
MAKING- FOLKS CAN JOIN ON ZOOM.
EVEN WHEN WE GO BACK IN PERSON
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT- PRESERVING
SOME KIND OF HYBRID APPROACH
WHERE FOLKS CAN STILL JOIN ON
pOUR MEETINGS WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW JUSTICE EQUITY
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION IT'S A
STANDING AGENDA ITEM- THAT WE
TALK ABOUT IT. REALLY AT EVERY
MEETING AND SO WE NOW HAVE
CREATED A VISION THAT'S BOTH
ABOUT SAFE AND EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO THE OUTDOORS. AND INCLUSIVE
DECISION MAKING THAT REFLECTS
THE NEEDS AND VALUES OF ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. THOSE TWO SORT
OF IMPORTANT CATEGORIES. JUST
GETTING FOLKS COMFORTABLE
HEARING A COMMISSION LIKE OURS
THAT'S A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
YEARS OLD- AND AS YOU MENTIONED
MATTER PRO TIME HAS NOT ALWAYS
LOOKS THE WY IT LOOKS NOW. JUST
GETTING FOLKS COME THROUGH WITH
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND CREATING
A WORK PLAN AND A POLICY THAT WE
CAN SORT OF. STAYED TRUE TO AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
DECISION MAKING I THINK THAT'S
REALLY POWERFUL AND IT'S A BIG
CHANGE JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS THAT'S REALLY GETTING
NOTICE. IN TERMS OF REACHING
FOLKS WHO ARE NOT ALREADY IN THE
ROOM- WE HAVE BEEN FORGING NEW
PARTNERSHIPS YOU KNOW I'LL SAY
THAT HAVING OUR NEW TRAVEL
ADVISOR ON BOARD. HAS BANNED I
CAN SEE THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
TRANSFORMATIVE IT ALREADY HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLY IMPACTFUL AND
HE'S NOT EVEN BEEN THERE A YEAR-
SO HAVING. ENHANCED CONNECTION
AND RELATIONSHIPS ARE TO BUILD
ON WHAT COMMISSIONER ALSO
KARMAZIN IS ALREADY VERY IMPACT
FULLY DONE- IS JUST REALLY
POWERFUL- HAVING. NEW
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FOLKS LIKE
HISPANIC ACCESS FOUNDATION
LATINO OUTDOORS NETWORK OUTDOOR
AFRO BROWN GIRL SURF- AND
ANOTHER SORT OF IDENTITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN CONSERVATION AND
GETTING OUTDOORS. I THINK IS
ALSO REALLY POWERFUL AND HAS A
LOT OF POTENTIAL- WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE BARRIERS FOR WHY
PEOPLE DON'T ENGAGE IN OUR
PROCESS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE RIGHT I AM A WHITE WOMAN-
WHO SITS ON THIS COMMISSION AND
HAS MY OWN LIVED EXPERIENCE AND
SO I CAN'T PRETEND TO GUESS WHAT
SOME OF THE BARRIERS ARE BUT-
CONNECTING TO NEW KINDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE NOT
ALREADY WELL CONNECTED TO. WE
TALKED ABOUT POTENTIALLY SENDING
OUT A SURVEY BROADLY I TO SORT
OF GAUGE AWARENESS OF OUR BODY
AND WHAT WE DO AND SEE WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO IN FOR FOLKS TO
WANT TO ENGAGE WITH US A LITTLE
BIT MORE I THINK THAT'S AN IDEA
AS WELL. WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
SOME OF OUR CHEN I WORKSHOPS
AFTER HOURS RIGHT SO. A LOT OF
PEOPLE WORK AND ARE NOT ABLE TO
COME TO OUR ALL DAY LONG TO DAY
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
MEETINGS SO HAVING DEDICATED
WORKSHOPS TALKS WHERE WE TALK
ABOUT CHEN I PRINCIPLES. FROM
FOUR TO SIX OR FIVE TO SEVEN IS
ANOTHER THING THAT WE'VE DONE TO
TRY TO REACH NEW FOLKS. SO I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE JUST SOME
OF THE IDEAS WE THOUGHT TAKEN
TOGETHER WITH- SOME OF THE R.
THREE- ACTION ITEMS THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE I WERE
HOPING THAT YOU KNOW IT'S A
JOURNEY I DON'T THINK THE AND
PLANES IS GOING TO BE ANY TIME
SOON. BUT JUST NORMALIZING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT EQUITY AND
JUSTICE AND INCLUSION AND
DIVERSITY IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
STAFF AND THESE NEW PARTNERSHIPS
AS WELL. I'M AS WE GO TO A
DOCTOR'S OF A LETTER I JUST HAVE
TO SAY I AM NOT SURE. THE PER
DIEM YOU GET FOR THIS IS. A NOT
FIT ALL IN TERMS OF THE MOVEMENT
I'M BEGINNING TO FEEL. BASED ON
WHAT YOU EACH ARE SHARING WITH
US TODAY- DOCTORS OF THE LEAD I
WANT TO CLOSE THIS OUT. THANK
YOU AND MAYBE I'LL START BY
RECOGNIZING THE INCREDIBLE WORK
THAT OUR STAFF DOES AND HOW MUCH
I APPRECIATED THAT AND MY FIRST.
TEN MONTHS ON THE COMMISSION
BECAUSE- THEY MAKE POSSIBLE. ALL
OF THE STUFF THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. AND I WANT
TO ADDRESS YOUR FIRST POINT. AND
I GUESS WHAT I CAN SAY THERE IS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT I MENTIONED
BEFORE THAT I THINK ABOUT
SCIENCE IS A PROCESS I DID A
PROCESS ON A BODY OF FACTS AND
SO. WHAT IS THAT PROCESS IT'S
TAKING OBSERVATIONS THAT'S
TAKING DATA. IT'S TAKING
KNOWLEDGE OF THE LANDSCAPE AND
THEN APPLYING IT TO
UNDERSTANDING JUST. QUESTIONS
LIKE. WHERE THE ANIMALS AND HOW
MANY ARE THERE AND WHAT IS GOING
ON IN THE SYSTEM AND SO- WHEN I
THINK OF SCIENCE I THINK OF SORT
OF THE BEST VERSION OF THAT AS
THE INTERGENERATIONAL KNOWLEDGE
THAT. ARE AT PARTNERS IN
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES BRING
TO THE TABLE I THINK THAT IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT AND UNDER
RECOGNIZED SOURCES OF
INFORMATION. TO FOR US TO USE
TECH GUIDE OUR DECISION MAKING
AND SO- REALLY REALLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT- WHAT YOU SAID AND I
THINK IT- THAT'S KIND OF THE
NEXT. PHASE FOR US IS- DICTATE.
LOOK BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE
BEEN. SETTING ASIDE AND IGNORING
- WITH THIS. TO HOW ENGAGE
CALIFORNIANS I'M A TRY TO BE
BRIEF I THINK THAT THAT. IS
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION WE ALL NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE ANSWER TO IS
TO UNDERSTAND WHO IS MISSING-
WHO IS NOT IN THIS CONVERSATION
WE'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE WHO ARE THOSE
COMMUNITIES. WHERE THEY LOOK
LIKE- I WAS DOWN ON THE NORTH
END OF THE BRIDGE IT OUTLINES
THE FISHING LAST WEEKEND AND- I
REALIZE YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW.
ANY OF THE LATINO FAMILIES WHO.
PULLED UP AND ARE FISHING UP
THERE ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON AND
I SHOULD I WANT TO UNDERSTAND
BETTER. YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE SO. UNDERSTANDING IS
MISSING AND THEN LISTENING-
BEFORE I BECAME SORT OF A CARD
CARRYING ECOLOGIST I WAS A
SOCIAL SCIENTIST AND REALLY THAT
IS ALL ABOUT LISTENING THAT'S
REALLY THE SCALE. THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CULTIVATE AND- SO
LISTENING IN OUR MEETINGS.
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS IN BED
MANY WAYS THAT- MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS. TALKED ABOUT IS
REALLY PARAMOUNT AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT'S IN THE FIELD IT'S
ALSO BY OUR PARTNERS- WE HAVE A
GREAT MANY PARTNERS IN THE
DEPARTMENT- IN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WHO CAN DO SOME OF
THAT LISTENING FOR US. AND HELP
US REACH SOME OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES WE DON'T EVEN
NECESSARILY KNOW ARE MISSING
FROM THE CONVERSATION. AT WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO
REACH OUT AND- I THINK ONCE WE
GET BACK TO IN PERSON MEETINGS
WITH THIS SORT OF HYBRID OPTIONS
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE. WITHOUT HAVING TO
TRAVEL AND MISS WORK. BUT ALSO
WE CAN BE IN A PLACE AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE MORE
DEEPLY WITH PEOPLE WHO KNOW THAT
PLACE- YOU KNOW THAT'S REALLY
GOING TO HELP. AND PERSONALLY I
HAVEN'T BEEN TO AN IN PERSON
MEETING AT THAT'S GOING TO HELP
ME UNDERSTAND AND LISTEN TO AND-
SORT OF ENGAGING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. THAT ARE GOING TO
BRING. MORE OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES IN THAT CONVERSATION
. WELL THANK YOU- I'M SO SORRY
THAT SENATOR COM LOGGERS AT
BUDGET SUB FIVE RIGHT NOW BUT-
SHE MAY HAVE A ROLE IN HELPING
TO FUND ENFORCEMENT PIECES OF
WHAT YOU DO SO- BUT I'M SORRY
SHE MISSED THIS THESE LAST FEW-
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S WHERE SHE STARTED
IN. HER QUESIONING IN TERMS OF-
THE DIVERSITY. BUT I JUST WANT
TO THANK EACH OF YOU FOR THOSE
INCREDIBLE. COMMENTS AND HELPING
US TO LEARN SOME THINGS AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR RECOGNIZE
AND STAFF- YOU COULDN'T DO WHAT
YOU DO WITHOUT. THEIR
INVOLVEMENT SO I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THAT RECOGNITION. WE
ARE ALL RIGHT NOW- AFTER A
REALLY EXPENSIVE WONDERFUL
CONVERSATION- SENATOR LAYERED IS
BACK FROM PRESENTING HIS BILL
SO- WE'RE SORRY YOU MISSED SOME
OF THE GREAT CONVERSATION BUT AS
FORMER SECRETARY. OF NATURAL
RESOURCES I'M SURE YOU KNOW
THESE ISSUES BETTER THAN MOST OF
US. OUT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
PUBLIC I AND HEAR FROM THEM%
BEFORE I COME BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES. FOR ABOUT A MOTION
I'M GONNA DO A REMINDER BEFORE I
START WITH THE- THOSE PRESENT
HERE WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK. A
REMINDER- THAT WE HAVE A TOLL
FREE NUMBER WHEN WE GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. AND I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT WE PUT THAT ON THE
SCREEN AGAIN IT'S ON OUR
WEBSITE. BUT THE NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 TOLL FREE NUMBER.
AND ACCESS CODE IS FOUR SEVEN
NINE FOUR ONE ONE. AND WITH THAT
I'M GOING TO OPEN IT UP HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK. AND WE
DO. I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW
EXCITED WE ARE TO SEE A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN PERSON-
WELCOME AND IF YOU COULD GIVE ME
YOUR NAME AT ANY ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT IF
ANY AND THEN YOUR COMMENTS
WELCOME. HOW TO- TOM RATIGAN
WITH THE SPORTFISHING
CONSERVANCY AND WE ARE KIND OF
HAPPY TO BE BACK IN THE ROOM TO
HELP WILL HOPEFULLY THIS IS A
CHANGES AND MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I THOUGHT IT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO COME UP
HERE. AND SPEAK I DON'T KNOW
DOCTORS AVALARA AND HAVEN'T
WORKED WITH HER BUT WITH-
COMMISSIONER HAROLD HARMISON.
KARMAZIN COMMISSIONER MURRAY OF
I'VE WORKED WITH BOTH OF THEM
FOR YEARS AND I DON'T WANT TO
SAY THAT THAT- THEY DO THEIR
HOMEWORK WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THESE ARE VERY
VERY COMPLEX ISSUES. WILL GO
EVERYTHING FROM FERRETS TO
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS AND IT'S
A WIDE RANGE AND- I CAN NEVER
REMEMBER BEING IN A FISHING GAME
COMMISSION. WHEN THEY WERE NOT
DOING THEIR HOMEWORK AND DIDN'T
HAVE A VERY GOOD UNDERSTANDING.
NUMBER TWO THEY LISTEN WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT STAKEHOLDERS
BEFORE. AND THEY TAKE THIS AND
THEY TAKE IT ALL IN AND THEY
WHERE. AND PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY. IN EACH AND EVERY
INSTANCE WE COME OUT WITH A FAIR
DECISION. IT MAY NOT BE EXACTLY
THE THINGS THAT THE OUTDOOR
COMMUNITY WANTS IT MAY NOT BE
THE HINGS THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY WANTS.
BUT THERE'S A VERY GOOD BALANCE
IN BETWEEN AND I COULD NOT GIVE
A HIGHER RECOMMENDATION THAN
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND FOR
COMING HERE TO GIVE IT- ANYONE
ELSE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. OKAY SEEING NO ONE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO- OUR
TELECONFERENCE AND WE WILL FIRST
TAKE- INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND WITH THAT-
LET ME WELCOME OUR MODERATOR WHO
WILL FACILITATE THAT
CONVERSATION TODAY VIA A
TELECONFERENCE WELCOME. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU AND
AS WE WAIT FOR THEM TO TEE UP
I'M JUST GOING TO REMIND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CALLING IN THAT WE
NEED YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION IF
ANY AND POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY SO WE CAN GET
YOUR TESTIMONY GO AHEAD MADAM
MODERATOR. THANK YOU I HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN Q. LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING YES WE CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN THIS IS
A REALLY GRIFFITH ON THE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WE'RE CALLING IN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL THREE OF
THESE CANDIDATES AUTHORITIES IN
THE VISUAL THE YOU HEARD ECHOED
MANY TIMES ON THE IN THE
TESTIMONY THEY BASE YOUR
DECISIONS ON SCIENCE AND WE
CAN'T ASK FOR MUCH MORE THAN
THAT SECONDLY AS WAS JST
PREVIOUSLY STATED THE
SENSIBILITY. AS AN NGO AND
SOMEONE TRYING TO WORK OUT- AND
REACH OUT TO THESE FOLKS AND
WORK WITH THEM ALL THREE OF
THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE
ON A YOU KNOW STRONG CALL THE
EMAIL AND VERY APPROACHABLE AT
THE COMMISSION WE USED TO HAVE
THE GOOD OLD DAYS OF. OF A
PHYSICAL COMMISSION MEETINGS ON
BREAKS AND WHAT HAVE YOU SO FOR
ALL THE REASONS STATED WE'RE IN
STRONG. SUPPORTER THESE
APPOINTMENTS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR
MIND TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO OUT.
HI AT THIS IS GARY RANGERS AND I
AM WITH I MEAN RESOURCE COMPANY%
AND- I AM THE MANAGER FOR
POOREST POLICY COMMUNICATION
WILL AT LEAST FOR TWO MORE DAYS
BECAUSE I'M RETIRING ON ON
FRIDAY- ALTRI THE CANDIDATES SAY
I DON'T KNOW TO THEM PERSONALLY
AT ALL THREE SEEM TO BE VERY
QUALIFIED BREACHED WITH THEIR
ACTIVITIES WITH THE COMMISSION
BUT I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF. A JACQUI ALSO
KARMAZIN- BUT NO JACQUI FOR A
LONG TIME HE'S A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF THE NORTH COAST- IS
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE FISH
WILDLIFE INDUSTRY REACHING
DIVERSE PART OF THE OF THE STATE
I WATCHED YOUR FOR SEVERAL YEARS
ON THE COMMISSION AND- SHE'S
ENGAGED SHE LISTENS CHS VERY
VERY. GOOD QUESTIONS- AND
CONSIDERS THE EVIDENCE BEFORE
BEFORE VOTING- HER INVOLVEMENT
THE TROUBLE COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY
PROVIDE SOME VERY UNIQUE-
PERSPECTIVE ON TRIBAL ISSUES AND
ENSURES A TRIBAL PREVALENT PUTS
ON FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
MATTERS- SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT- THAT SHE BE
CONFIRMED BEFORE TO THE FLOOR.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
RETIREMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU SO
. THE THANK YOU I LIVE IN PLEASE
AT. THANK YOU AFTERNOON THAT I'M
OUT OF BREATH DOWN IN SENATOR
ASSIST WYNNE RECORD OUR ARTICLE
INTERNET. OUTDOOR WORKING ITSELF
. CALIFORNIA'S LODGE ALL
CONSERVE HUNTING INTEREST GROUPS
AND SUPPORT OF ALL OF THESE
COMMISSIONERS- OUR CRITERIA WORK
I'M HONORED TO SUPPORT THEM IS
WHETHER THEY'RE FAIR. THEIR
OPENING OPEN TO LEARN AND THAT
THEY HAVE A FINE OKAY ALL THREE
HAVE REPRESENTED THEIR I'VE HAD
THE PLEASURE TO ENDORSE-
COMMISSIONER CARMEN FOUND IN THE
PAST. AND HER CONTRIBUTIONS OVER
THE YEARS I THINK IT'S BEEN
STATED BY ALL. IS VERY
COMMENDABLE PARTICULARLY FOR
LEADERSHIP ON TRIBAL ISSUES.
THAT THAT ORIGINAL. IN DIVERSITY
TO COMMISSION THAT MUCH NEED. I
UP. THE ARTS COM TODAY. AND
EQUITY ACCESS IS REALLY AT THE
HEART OF MY OF OUR- WORK. AND WE
WOULD WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR A DEEPER PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP ON MORE ACCESS AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR ALL OF WHICH
NOW I REALLY WANNA- COMMAND
ACTUALLY THE SENATE FOR A YEAR
BOB FOX HOLDEN TO SPEND ONE OF
THE- BEST CONFIRMATION HEARING
I'VE NEVER PARTICIPATED IN. AND
I LEARNED A GREAT DEAL AND IF I
MAY SAY I DON'T THINK IT YOUR
GRANDFATHER'S ROLE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINES
PLEASE COLLECT. WELL CARE ATKINS
- THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BOTH MY THAT THE
GERMAN THE RINCON BATTLE SAY NEW
ENGINES I'M ALSO PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN LUIS REY ENGINE WATER
AUTHORITY- I SPEAK HERE AND SOME
. OF THE JACQUI AUSSTELLER
ROBINSON- BET ON THAT BUT AND I
. TREBALI. GENDRE STANDS UP
SHE'S THE OF RELY ON THE HOOP UP
IT IN. WHAT THE TO MEMBERS THE
OTHER COMMITTEE I TO HAVE ARE TO
WORK WITH YEAH. BUT I TO ISSUES
OF WILL BE COVERING. WITH THE
COMMISSION THIS YEAR. AS A LOCAL
PUBLIC LAW. EIGHTY THREE TO
EIGHTY. WHICH DEALS WITH HUNTING
AND FISHING RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
INDIANS. LEAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS OVERSTEPPED- WHAT
IS STATED. IN THAT LAW WHICH
STATES CLEARLY. NOTHING IS TO
INTERFERE WITH HUNTING FISHING
AND TRAPPING THE RIGHTS OF
INDIANS. SO I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS I WILL THE COMMISSION OF
THIS YEAR ALSO WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. THE STEELHEAD TROUT
PROJECT IT IS WANTS TO BE WE
WOULD LOVE IT IF PEOPLE WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THE STILL THE TROUT
CUDDLING UP ASSEMBLY THREE
RIVER. LIKE YOU DID MANY YEARS
AGO. THAT NOT A REALITY. WE'RE
FIGHTING NOW JUST TO MAINTAIN IT
PROTECT THE GROUNDWATER. SO I
THINK THAT SHOULD BE LOOKED AT
CAREFULLY HOW MUCH MONEY THE
LIMITED MONEY THAT'S THEIR- DO
WE SPEND ON TRYING TO GET THIS
DEAL THAT DROUGHT IN THE SUMMER
THREE RIVERS THAT JUST CAN'T
HAPPEN. SO THAT'S THE THING I
OPEN UP THE COMMISSION LOOK AT.
AGAIN A STRONG SUPPORTER OF-
JACKIE US THAT WE'RE ALMOST DONE
THANK YOU. KAREN THANK YOU AND
I'M SURE THE COMMISSIONERS- TOOK
THOSE COMMENTS TO HEART AND- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY
PLEASE GO AT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CANNON CENTER LAYERED THIS
IS JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF
OF A FLUID CONDITION
STAKEHOLDERS NINE FORTUNATE TO
WORK WITH INCLUDING OCEANA OCEAN
CONSERVANCY THE CALIFORNIA
FISHING A MORNING SUPERVISORS
AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION A
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM AND THE
MEDIA DOESN'T MEAN IT. THIS IS A
VERY EXCITING DAY I JUST WISH I
WAS THERE IN PERSON AND WE ARE
SO IMPRESSED BY AND SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE WILLINGNESS OF THESE
OUTSTANDING COMMISSIONERS TO
SERVE. THEIR OVERALL DEMAND HI
TIME FOR ENTER AT AND THOUGHT.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE CHALLENGES
BY A GLOBAL PANDEMIC A
BIODIVERSITY CRISIS AND MANY
CLIMATE DRIVEN PRACTICE OUR
ASTRAL AND MARINE WILDLIFE I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU MONICA
TIME THAT THEY DESERVE HIGHER
PRETTY ON. IF THEY CAN WIN
ARKANSAS AND I'M HAVE A WAY OR
LOSER NINE AM THAT. BOTH
COMMITMENT TO FINDING SOLUTIONS
WEDDING R. PA. AND STOMACH FOR
TAKING HARD WHERE THEY NOT IT IS
STOLEN. THAT COMMISSION ARE. AND
ACTIVE ENGAGE. WE APPRECIATE THE
THAT THEY CAN START AND BALANCE
BRIAN WITH A BALL SOCIETAL AND-
BECAUSE OF ALL READ THAT. IT IS
IN MY JUST THAT HOW WE MANAGE
OUR STATE WHILE AND HABITAT THEY
DEPEND. SO MANY OTHER FACTORS
ALSO RIGHT MATTER I CAN. AND I
HAVE A FINALLY- SPEAKING UP FOR
MYSELF AFTER NEARLY YEARS THE A
WITH IT HOW FISHING COMMISSION I
CAN ATTACH TO THE ROOM TO THAT'S
OCCURRED. AND WHILE I CAN NAY
SOMEONE MAN SO HELPED MAKE SO I
BELIEVE FEMALE LEADER ON STAFF
AND COMMISSION HAD MEANT FRENCH
I'M- FEMALE COMMISSION BRING IN
THE PERSONAL GROWTH AND PRIDE
AND SATISFACTION SO WE THINK
COMMISSIONER MURRAY CAR WITHIN
ABOUT A LACK. CLIMATE THAN
ANYTHING FOR A- AND TO CONFIRM
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH LET
ME JUST CAN FOR WHO MAY BE AND
THAT AYE AYES LAYER IS DEAF HERE
BUT- ROOM IS THE VICE CHAIR.
SENATOR BATES SENATOR JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW THERE'S
ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT HERE AND US
SENATOR COM LONGER WILL BE BACK
AS SOON AS SHE IS DONE IN BUDGET
SUB FIVE MADAME. MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE GOOD
AFTERNOON ATKINS AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
DRISKELL I'M CONGRESSMAN JARED
HAPPENS SENIOR DISTRICT
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE NORTH
COAST AND- I'M CALLING IN TODAY
TO EXPRESS THE CONGRESS AND
SUPPORT FOR JACQUI HOUSE THERE-
COMES REAPPOINT TO THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION AND- HE ASKED ME TO
MAKE A STATEMENT ON. TOXIC ARMS
AND THE HALF WEALTHY SAKE I WITH
IN WASHINGTON. I YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M HARPER- KARMAZIN MISTER ON
THE COMMITTEE SINCE TWO THIRD
AND- AGAIN A STRONG AT THE TIM
TRIED RIGHT AS WELL AS ACT TO.
AND WHY. ARE FOR ALL I WANT LIKE
FOR ALL ACCOUNTS- HUFFMAN GET.
REP MORE TRIED THAN ANY
CONGRESSIONAL IN THE LOWER FORTY
EIGHT STATES. AND- MISS PARKER
AFTERWARDS ON THE FISHING GAME.
HAVE BEEN REALLY REPRESENTED A
STRONG STEP FORWARD AND
RECOGNIZING HOW MANAGEMENT FOR
TRIBES AND PROTECTION. OF THE
STATE'S VITAL NATURAL RESOURCES
. AND SHE'S TRANSIT ON THE
COMMISSION- WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
JUNK GROUP CONDITIONS. PROTECT
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND PROMOTED-
GATHERED DATA GATHERING AND USE
OF SOUND SCIENCE CRAFTING OUR
POSITION SO. TODAY CONGRESSMAN
HUFFMAN IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
JACKIE HAAS OR HAARMS. LONG AT
THE FOR TRIBESMEN FOR.
CONSERVATION AND RECREATION THE
CALIFORNIA GAME COMMISSION. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE- TO ON HER
TODAY. TAKE CARE THANK YOU
PLEASE THANK THE FOR HIS HIS
TESTIMONY TODAY NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MY NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BYE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S MARKEDLY
WITH CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO SAY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT- MISTER HOPPER
PROMETHEAN MYTH THAT ALLOWED TO
AND MISS MARIE CONFIRMATION TO
THE COMMISSION WE'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH ALL THREE
OF THESE COMMISSIONERS. AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF FINANCE AND THE NEED TO
CONSERVE CALIFORNIA'S FISH AND
WILDLIFE POPULATIONS IN A
SUSTAINABLE WAY OVER LONG TERM.
THEY ALSO UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
HUNTING AND FISHING ACTIVITIES
AND HOW THEY PROVIDE IMPORTANT-
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISHING GAME SPECIAL WILDLIFE.
OVERALL CONSERVATION EFFORTS.
ALL OF ALWAYS VERY. AND WILLING
TO LISTEN THE CALIFORNIA WATER
POLICY CONCERNS ON A VARIETY OF
ISSUES. YOUR OWN WHEN WE MIGHT
DISAGREE- THEY ALSO CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND TO THE NEED TO
PROVIDE INCREASED ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO THE OUTDOORS AND
COURSES INCLUDES FOR WATERFOWL
HUNTING THOUGH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOUR MIND TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- ADAM
PROGRAM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FRANK MOLINA- WE HAVE THE
SEMINAL BAND MEASURES IS SPANISH
YOU. IN PARTICULAR GERMAN
KENNETH KAHN. HOSTETLER
ACHIEVING A GREAT ADVOCATE BUT
ALL THREE ARE VERY WELL
QUALIFIED AND SHORTFALL IN
SUPPORT OF THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAMES TODAY SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEER
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA BOWMAN
UNDERSTATE ARCHERY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HOW GOOD FOR
CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION AND
NINE OTHER WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CONFIRMATION ALL THREE OF
THESE COMMISSIONERS. WE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH WITH MR
HOSLER CARDS IN FOR EIGHT YEARS
WITH COMMISSIONER MURRAY FOR
THREE YEARS AND YOU'RE READY FOR
A FULL YEAR WOULD. COMMISSIONER
GOT AWAY AND WE HAVE FOUND ALL
THREE ARE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMISSION TAKING THE TIME
TO LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS. TAKE
A LOOK AT THE SCIENCE AND THE
BALANCE YOU KNOW PUBLIC
SENTIMENT AS WELL IN MAKING THE
DECISION TO COME BEFORE THIS
BODY WE HAVE SUBMITTED DETAILED
LETTERS ON ALL THREE THROUGH
THE- TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY SO
YOU HAVE THAT BACK UP BUT WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THEIR CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OF MORE WITNESSES. THANK YOU I
HAVE FURTHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN A MOMENT
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. ARE LOOKING RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. I SEE
NOBODY APPROACH AND- THE PODIUM
SO MADAM MODERATOR LET ME COME
BACK TO YOU. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THEY WANT TO PARTICIPATE
BY TELECONFERENCE- AND REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END OF THE ROW AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. MAN MODERATOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH- WILL TALK WITH YOU
A LITTLE LATER IN THE HEARING
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP I AND
BEFORE I TAKE IN MOTION AND I AM
READY TO GO TO YOU I JUST WANT
TO DEFEND MY GRANDFATHER'S
BECAUSE I KNEW I'D GET IN
TROUBLE ON THAT STATEMENT. BOTH
GREAT HUNTERS BOTH GREAT FARMERS
AND WITH THAT I'M STILL
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FISHING GAME
COMMISSIONERS BEFORE US SENATOR
LAYERED I ACTUALLY WANT TO TAKE
THE UNUSUAL. STEP OF MAKING A
COMMENT BEFORE MOTION PLAN DO
AND I TOO ENJOYED- THE- KATHY
WHICH IS COMMON ABOUT THIS IS
NOT YOUR GRANDFATHER'S RULES
COMMITTEE AS WELL. I THINK
THAT'S RIGHT R. ONE RANDOM
COMMENT FIRST JUST THE REASON
THIS IS THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION AND THE DEPARTMENT
TEN YEARS AGO BECAME THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT IS THE
NAME OF THE COMMISSION IS IN THE
STATE CONSTITUTION SO WE COULD
CHANGE THE NAME OF THE
DEPARTMENT BUT WE HAVE TO WAIT
TO SOME OPPORTUNE MOMENT TO HAVE
THE NAME OF THE COMMISSION FALLS
SO HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS WITH THOSE OF US AROUND
THIS TABLE BEING HERE WE CAN
FIND A PLACE WHERE THAT CAN
HAPPEN. BUT THE COMMENT I REALLY
WANT TO MAKE IS THAT. ON MY VERY
FIRST DAY AS RESOURCES SECRETARY
I GOT A CALL FROM A STATE
SENATOR. WEST BROKE. WHO CALLED
AND SAID I WANT TO INTRODUCE A
BILL. THAT REALLY REMOVES TRIBES
FROM THE MARINE PROTECTED AREA
PROCESS. AND AFTER GAUGING WITH
HIM FOR A FEW DAYS I SAID I KNOW
HOW ARE YOU MEANT IN THE
LEGISLATURE. YOU DON'T HAVE
DEMAND THE GUTS OF THE BILL AND
UNTIL APRIL. WOULD YOU GIVE ME
TELL APRIL TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
TRIBES AND SEE IF I CAN FIND. AN
ADEQUATE SOLUTION. AND SO I DID
IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS BLUE OP
ARE ONCE. BUT WE GOT TO A
LANDMARK AGREEMENT THAT SAID.
THAT IN MARINE PROTECTED AREAS
IN THE CONSERVATION AREAS OF THE
TRIBE CAN. DEMONSTRATE A
HISTORIC TAKE FOR SUBSISTENCE
FOR CEREMONIAL PURPOSES THEY CAN
DO THAT IN THE CONSERVATION
AREA. AND IT TOOK TRIBES ONCE
THE COMMISSION APPROVED IT FROM
OPPOSITION TO MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS. TO SUPPORT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CAME UP IN THAT
PROCESS. WAS A TRIBAL. OF PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA FEELING WHAT THEY
WANT REPRESENTED ON THIS
COMMISSION THAT THEY WERE NOT
WITHIN IT AND SO ONE OF THE
FIRST APPOINTMENT STUFF WAS MADE
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. OF WAS
JACQUI HOSLER KARMA'S. AND I
THINK THAT TODAY'S TESTIMONY IS
A TRIBUTE TO THE FACT THAT SHE
LIVED UP TO EVERYTHING THAT WAS
THE REASON THAT WE WANTED HER ON
THE COMMISSION IN THE FIRST
PLACE THE FACT THAT IMMEDIATELY.
A TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVE OR STOP
IN THE HALLWAY AND SAY HOW DO I
INTERACT WITH THE SYSTEM. AND WE
HAD TO FLUSH OUT THINGS OVER
TIME THAT WERE IN THAT AGREEMENT
SUCH AS WHAT IS SUBSISTENCE WERE
NOW ON THE COMMISSION HE'S
WORKING ON THE DEFINITION OF
SUBSISTENCE. AND TRIBES ARE
UNIQUE IN CALIFORNIA AND MANY OF
THEM HAVE THEIR OWN RESOURCES I
BELIEVE THAT THE TRINIDAD
RANCHERIA WERE JACQUI WORKS. IS
ONE THAT HAS ITS OWN FAULTS AND
SO THEY WANTED TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ENFORCE JOINT AND POWER JACKIE
IS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
DISCUSSION ON A POTENTIAL
AGREEMENT ON WHAT CO MANAGEMENT
REALLY IS TO REPRESENT THE
ASSETS THAT COME FROM THE
TRIBES. AND PUT THEM WITH OF THE
ASSETS OF THE STATE AND IN A
COOPERATIVE WAY MOVE AHEAD ON
MARINE PROTECTION. AND SO IT IS
AN AMAZING THING AND SAMANTHA
MARIE WAS AT ALMOST ALL THOSE
MEETINGS ADVOCATING AND ERICA-
SUMMER WEATHER IS A SCIENTIST
AND NOW IN THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT I DEBATED SAYING THIS
BECAUSE I KNOW IT MIGHT BE
CONTROVERSIAL. AMONG CERTAIN
PARTIES THERE ARE MORE
SCIENTISTS THAN THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT DOWN THERE
ARE WARDENS OR WILDLIFE OFFICERS
AND IT'S BECAUSE AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES SAID. THERE IS A
TRIBUTE TO SCIENCE. AND SO WHEN
VACANCIES ON THIS COMMISSION
CAME UP TEN AND TWELVE YEARS
AGO. ONE OF THE MOST FASCINATING
THINGS AS THE WITNESSES WE JUST
HAD WILL PROBABLY SPLIT DOWN THE
MIDDLE ON THOSE APPOINTMENTS AND
SO HERE WE ARE TODAY. WITH THREE
COMMISSIONERS WITH A DIVERSE
BACKGROUND. THAT REALLY HAVE HAD
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE PART OF
THE COMMISSION. THAT HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AMONG THE
WITNESSES. FROM PEOPLE THAT
COULDN'T AGREE ON COME
MISSIONERS IN THE POINT. SO I
THINK THIS IS JUST AN AMAZING
STEP FORWARD IT'S AMAZING
TRIBUTE TO WHERE THE COMMISSION
IS NOW. AND THE FACT THAT IT'S
RESPONSIVE AND SCIENCE BASED
PEOPLE MIGHT THINK IT TIPS ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER. ABOUT THAT
PEOPLE FEEL REPRESENTED THAT IF
YOUR TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVE YOU
SEE YOURSELF ON THE DIESS IF YOU
GO TO A MEETING SO- IT'S JUST
WITH GREAT PLEASURE GREAT PRIDE
THAT I MOVED THE CONFIRMATION OF
THESE THREE POINT. SENATOR THANK
YOU LET ME DO ONE TECHNICAL
THING I'M LOOKING AT MY
COLLEAGUES AND WE DO NOT NEED TO
SPLIT THE MOTION ONE MOTION FOR
THREE IS GOOD FOR ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES. OKAY THANK YOU I'M-
SENATOR LEVIN I DON'T USUALLY
SAY ANYTHING BEFORE WE VOTE
AFTER THE MOTION HAS BEEN MADE
BUT LET ME JUST EXTEND MY
APPRECIATION TO YOU AND IN YOUR
FORMER ROLE R. AS SECRETARY AND
TO EACH OF THESE FOLKS WHO WERE
PART OF THIS DISCUSSION WHICH
OBVIOUSLY MADE THIS HEARING
TODAY MUCH MORE OF A- EASY-
APPOINTMENT PROCESS FOR ALL OF
US ON ON THE COMMITTEE I THINK
WE RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO THIS SO I. APPRECIATE
YOUR MOTION AND- MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KAMLAGER HI I'M LONGER I LAYERED
HI THERE I ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE. BATES SENATOR BATES AYE ON
ITEMS ONE EIGHT ONE B. AND ONE
C. THANK YOU BATES I GROWTH. THE
GIRLS I ON ITEMS AND GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED TO HEAR
ITEM AND EIGHTY D. N. C. GROVE I
FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE TO ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS TO EACH OF YOU
AND OUR INCREDIBLE THANKS TO
EACH OF YOU THESE APPOINTMENTS
WILL BE FORWARDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. EACH
AND EVERY SENSE- AND SPECIAL
THANKS TO SENATOR LARRY. THANK
YOU HAVE A GREAT REST OF YOUR
DAY AND- WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH MY COLLEAGUES ARE
FINE WITH THAT- WE HAVE A TWO
MORE APPOINTEES WHO HAVE BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY AND I THINK AS
I CAN SEE ON THE SCREEN
LISTENING INTENTLY FRANKLY- SO I
WANT TO- MOVED TO. GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
ITEMS ONE D. AND ONE D. THESE
ARE APPOINTMENTS. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND OUR- MISTAKES
C. L. LOPEZ AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES. WELCOME AND MISS
KRISTEN K. MONTGOMERY AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION SERVICES.
I'M GONNA SAY WELCOME TO BOTH OF
YOU AND WE WILL FOLLOW. THE
SAME- KIND OF PROCESS WE DID
BEFORE ALLEN BY EACH OF YOU TO-
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE
WITH YOU THAT YOU WANT TO THANK
ARE RECOGNIZED GO RIGHT INTO
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS. I THEY
WILL GO TO THE NEXT APPOINTEE
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO SENATORS
TO ASK QUESTIONS AND MAKE
COMMENTS SO I'M GONNA START TO
MISS LOPEZ AND WELCOME YOU
FIRST. AND AFTER YOU MOVE A
FINISHER INTRODUCTIONS AND
OPENING COMMENTS I WILL GO TO
MISS MONTGOMERY WHAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ABOUT- WAS QUITE
FASCINATING I LEARNED QUITE A
BIT AND THE LAST UP- OUR IN
HOUSE OF THANK YOU. I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. I LIKE TO START BY
THANKING MY FAMILY WHO ARE
WATCHING TODAY FOR ALL OF THEIR
LOVE. AND SUPPORT TODAY AND
ALWAYS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY CVC OUR FAMILY WHO HAVE
BEEN THERE PROVIDING GUIDANCE
AND SUPPORT OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR YEARS. I BEGAN THIS JOURNEY
AS A STUDENT ASSISTANT WHILE
ATTENDING COLLEGE AND STARTING
STARTED WORKING FOR CDCR IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. I CONTINUE
TO PROMOTE WILL HELP MANY OF THE
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT I NOW
OVERSEE IS DIRECTOR. THERE ARE
MANY MANY POSITIVE CHANGES SINCE
I BEGAN WITH YOU SEE ARE AND.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
OUR MISSION. DURING MY TIME WITH
DEPARTMENT I SEE. MANAGED
MULTIPLE CHALLENGING ASSIGNMENTS
INCLUDING THE STATE'S LARGEST
STAFFING REDUCTIONS AS A RESULT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT.
REOPENING THE CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICER ACADEMY. IMPLEMENTING
SOME NECESSARY LARGE SCALE
HIRING EFFORTS AND SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDING THE DEPARTMENT'S
EMPLOYEE TRAINING EFFORTS. AS
DIRECTOR OF THE LARGEST
WORKFORCE IN STATE GOVERNMENT I
WILL CONTINUE TO PROMOTE AND
INCREASE WORKFORCE DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. LEVERAGE
TECHNOLOGY ENHANCE CUSTOMER
SERVICE PLANS AND ENSURE THAT
STOPPER ONBOARDED AND TRAINED
EFFICIENTLY. I'M GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR MY APPOINTMENT ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
AFFECTING CHANGE US THE DIRECTOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES FOR CPR
AND I REALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
LOPEZ I MISS MY GOVERNMENT WILL
NOW TURN TO YOU WELCOME. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHRIS MONTGOMERY AND I'M
APPEARING BEFORE YOU TODAY AS A
DIRECTOR OF ENTERPRISE
INFORMATION SERVICES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION I WANT TO THANK
MY FAMILY FOR ALL THE SUPPORT
THEY PROVIDE TO ME THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER ESPECIALLY NOW THROUGH
THIS CONFIRMATION PROCESS. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR POINTING ME TO THIS
POSITION AND THE CDC OUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AND CONFIDENCE IN ME AND MY EIS
TEAM FOR THEIR SUPPORT HARD WORK
AND THEIR DEDICATION AND
COMMITMENT TO THE CITY
FOUNDATION. PRIOR TO CDCR I
WORKED AS A PROJECT MANAGEMENT
AND CHANGE MANAGEMENT CONSULTANT
FOR SEVERAL YEARS. I JOIN STATE
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO I CALPERS
AS CONTROLLER OVER ACCOUNTING
TREASURY MANAGEMENT. I'VE NEVER
SEEN YOU SEE OUR DOCTOR ABOUT
FOUR YEARS I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT DOES. AND
THE TOOLS BOTH STAFF AND THE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE NEED TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS. AS A
DIRECTOR OF THE I. S. I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
SPRINGS TECHNOLOGY THIS FORCED
TO WORK IN THE DEPARTMENT. WHILE
I DO NOT SET THE POLICY GOALS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. I WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE PROGRAM AREAS
TO ENSURE WE'RE MEETING THE
GOALS AND OUTCOMES. I BELIEVE MY
BACKGROUND IN BUSINESS AND
CHANGE MANAGEMENT ARE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THE DEPARTMENT. AS
A CONTINUES AS PER REMOTE WORK
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE R.
CARSON AT PARKS RATED AND THEIR
LOVED ONES AND OTHER NEW
PROJECTS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE SERVICE
AND SUPPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND WORKING WITH MY TEAM TO LEAD
THEM TO SUCCESS. I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR. TO PEER
BEFORE ALL OF YOU TODAY I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE FOR ME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SENATOR COME LONGER YOU
WANNA KICK A SAUCE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- Q. HAVE A
PREFERENCE FOR HOW YOU WANT US
TO ASK QUESTIONS WITH TO WHOM I
OF I THANK YOU FOR- SAYING THAT
I SHOULD HAVE PICKED UP ON THAT.
REALIZE AND MOVING FROM THE
COMMISSIONERS OR THE GAME WHO
ARE ALL THE SAME POSITION- IF
YOU WILL DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL- BECAUSE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT POSITIONS I RECOGNIZE
THAT SO THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR THAT
INSTRUCTION I WILL- START WITH
MISS LOPEZ I WANT TO THANK YOU I
WANT TO THANK BOTH OF YOU- FOR
GRANTING ME A FEW MINUTES
YESTERDAY TO- OR MONDAY I CAN'T
REMEMBER TO- TALK WITH YOU ABOUT
YOUR WORK SO. I WILL ONLY ASK
ONE QUESTION OF EACH OF YOU.
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAD A SOME
GOOD TIME- MISS LOPEZ I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK YOU. THE QUESTION
ABOUT THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS- YOU KNOW WE HAD A NICE
DISCUSSION ABOUT- BULLYING
INTIMIDATION- OF STRESS ANXIETY
WITH THE STAFF- AND- SUICIDE
RATES- WITH THE STAFF- INSIDE-
CDCR. AND WE TALKED ABOUT
TRAINING AND OBVIOUSLY. MORE
MONEY AND RESOURCES AND I THINK
WE BOTH AGREE THAT. YOU KNOW THE
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS ON THE
ISSUES ISN'T ALWAYS MORE MONEY
OR MORE TRAINING- I'M BUT HOW DO
WE SUPPORT. FOLKS WHO ARE
WORKING WITHIN CDC ARE SO THAT
THEY FEEL SUPPORTED THEY FEEL
SAFE- WITHIN THE SYSTEM TO
REGISTER LEVELS OF ANXIETY OR
FEAR OR STRESS OR DEPRESSION
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION THAT
PEOPLE CAN FEEL SAFE AND
COMFORTABLE TO RAISE ISSUES OF
CONCERN. WITHOUT FEELING LIKE
THERE WILL BE RETALIATION AND
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
PREVENT- HOW DO WE CREATE A
CULTURE WHERE FOLKS FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN WORK- AND WE DON'T END
UP HEARING ABOUT MEN AND WOMEN
WHO- ARE TAKING THEIR OWN LIVES-
BECAUSE OF. YOU KNOW THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON WITHIN THE
DIFFERENT PRISONS- YOU KNOW AS A
ROLE RESULT OF THE CULTURE SO
I'D LOVE IT IF YOU COULD JUST
SORT OF. RESPOND TO THAT THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR
ABSOLUTELY- SO WITH. AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING I'VE
BEEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOR
OVER TWENTY FOUR YEARS I THINK
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF CHANGE- EVEN
WITH THAT OUR CULTURE AS WELL- I
THINK THAT WHAT COMES. WHAT
REALLY IS- COMES TO MIND IS THE
LEADERSHIP MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE- COMMITTED TO MAKING CHANGES
OR COMMITTED TO LISTENING TO
WHAT IS GOING ON. WHAT I FOUND
MOST USEFUL WAS GOING OUT TO THE
INSTITUTIONS MEETING WITH THE
STAFF AND TALKING TO THEM AND
SEEING WHAT CAN WHAT CAN WE DO
TO HELP WITH THIS CHANGE. AND
GAINING THE TRUST OF OUR
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
ONE THING THAT NOT ALL-
EVERYBODY IS BEING LISTENED TO
IN SOME REGARDS BECAUSE WE ARE
MOVING SOMETIMES REALLY QUICKLY
AND THAT'S NOT AN EXCUSE. BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
DO AS LEADERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
MESSAGING. IS REACHING ALL OF
OUR SUPERVISORS MANAGERS AND OUR
STOP IN ENSURING THAT WE'RE
EDUCATING OUR STOCK ALSO ON THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND WHAT
AVENUES THERE ARE FOR THEM TO
TAKE IF THEY FEEL. THAT THEY
NEED TO- YOU TAKE IT TO THAT
LEVEL BUT AGAIN I THINK THE IT
GETS BACK TO THE COMMUNICATION
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE TALKED
ABOUT YESTERDAY IN.
COMMUNICATION WITH ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THE WORK
EVERY DAY WE SHOULD BE MAKING
THE DECISIONS JUST BASED ON
SITTING IN OUR OFFICES WE SHOULD
BE GETTING OUT THERE LISTENING
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING. AND I KNOW
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE HAPPENING
THAT- WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
ADDRESS AND WHEN WE DO NOT
PEOPLE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE ALL THOSE THINGS. WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT TRADING AS
WELL. I ALWAYS USE HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF MY TIME IN TRAINING AND
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES WE THROW
TRAINING OUT IF THERE'S AN ISSUE
LET'S JUST TRAIN PEOPLE BUT
THERE HAS TO BE MORE TO JUST THE
TRAINING PIECE. I THINK TRAINING
IS VERY CRITICAL AND ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE RESOURCES
AGAIN. AND EDUCATION OF WHAT IS
GOING ON AND FOR US YOU CAN DO
COMING. EFFECTIVELY YOU KNOW
FROM OUR POSITIONS IT AS THE
LEADERS. SO I DEFINITELY THINK
THAT SOMETHING WALKEN'S WE'VE I
DON'T THINK SORRY. IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
DO- AS MOVING FORWARD BUT I WILL
SAY. THAT I DO SEE A LOT OF
PROGRESS OVER THE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE. AND THAT GIVES
ME- THANK AS WE HOPE AS WELL
THAT WE WILL EVENTUALLY GET TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT M. AND I THINK GIVEN
THE FACT WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
NON CUSTODIAL STAFF RIGHT HOW WE
CAN RETAIN RECRUIT AND RETAIN
FOLKS YOU KNOW AS COOKS AND
JANITORS AN ADMIN YOU KNOW THAT
BEING ABLE TO RETAIN RECRUIT AND
RETAIN THOSE POSITIONS. ARE
SUCCESSFULLY WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL FOCUS ON THE
CUSTODIAL STAFF RIGHT IN MAKING
SURE THAT THEY FEEL- SUPPORTED
AND PROTECTED- YOU KNOW IT SORT
OF GOES BOTH WAYS SO I KNOW WHAT
I'M NOT GONNA ASK ABOUT THE
OTHER ONE BUT- IT'S THE CYCLE OF
LIFE. I'M MISS MONTGOMERY I
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON A
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD- THE
OTHER DAY AS WELL I THINK I'D
ASK YOU ABOUT. CBSA THE COMPUTER
VOICE STRESS ANALYZER- AND SO
THE CLARIFICATION THAT I GOT IS
THAT CVS SAY IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT INVESTIGATIONS INTO
THREAT ASSESSMENTS IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS- IT'S SO IT'S BEING
UTILIZED. ARM AND I KNOW YOU
SAID IN YOUR INTRODUCTION THAT
YOU DON'T CREATE THE POLICY BUT
YOU'RE CERTAINLY IMPLEMENTING
OPERATIONAL ISING IT AND I DO
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFERENCE- BUT
GIVEN THAT. CVS SAY- TENDS TO
PRODUCE FALSE OR COMPROMISE
REPORTS IT HAS AN ACCURACY RATE
OF ABOUT 8% YOU KNOW I'M
WONDERING YOUR THOUGHTS ON. WHY
WE ARE USING THIS TECHNOLOGY-
AND WHAT OTHER ALTERNATIVES
THERE ARE FOR US. TO GET THE
KIND OF INFORMATION WE NEED-
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE MORE
ACCURATE AND CAN PASSED STRESS
TESTS. WHEN IT COMES TO BEING
CREDIBLE. BECAUSE I THINK 8%
ACCURACY IS KIND OF LOW. THANK
SENATOR- IS AS AS I DISCUSSES
ACTUALLY- FALLS OUT OF FALLS
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF MY ROLE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT- AND I CAN
CERTAINLY PUT YOU IN TOUCH WITH
THE PEOPLE THAT CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- IT AS A- TALK ABOUT
SHOULD SHOULD THE PROGRAM NEEDS
THIS TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY. BUT WE
REALLY DO IS LOOK AT WITH THAT
WORK WITH THE PROGRAMS TO- GET
THE LOOK AT THE PROCUREMENT
TRYING TO WORK WITH THEM ON
IMPLEMENTING THE TECHNOLOGY
BASED ON THE POLICY BASED ON THE
REGULATIONS THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
ANY PROCEDURES DIVIDE. DEFINED
BY THEM- SO- WITH THAT- I CAN
CERTAINLY PUT THEM IN TOUCH WITH
SOMEBODY IN TOUCH WITH YOU TO
THAT QUESTION. WELL THAT WOULD
BE GREAT BUT I GUESS IF THE IDEA
IS TO. BE ABLE TO. ASSESS
THREATS. WHICH IS A POLICY HOW
DO WE DO THIS THEN SOMEONE MADE
A DECISION TO PROCURE THIS KIND
OF SOFTWARE OR EQUIPMENT. AND
WHO'S THE ONE WHO SAYS HEY
PEOPLE. WE DON'T GET GREAT
RESULTS LET'S NOT- YOU KNOW
IMPLEMENT THIS I MEAN THAT'S HOW
I GET OF ADS AND SO I'M NOT
GOING TO PUT YOU ON THE SPOT. IF
THAT'S NOT YOU I GUESS WHO IS IT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
MAKES SENSE FOR US TO BE
IMPLEMENTING SOFTWARE THAT COSTS
A LOT THAT ISN'T PRODUCING THE
KIND OF RESULTS THAT WE WANT TO
GET IN ULTIMATELY THE RESULTS WE
WANT TO GET. ARE ACCURATE
RESULTS. YOU MIGHT MATH YES THE
AND AGAIN I THINK- I WOULD LOOK
TO MAKE THE PROGRAM AREAS TO
ANSWER THAT TYPE OF QUESTION I
THINK THERE ARE- PEOPLE ARE-
PROGRAM AREAS YOU JERK DIFFERENT
TOOLS AND I THINK THAT THEY CAN
THEY WOULD BE BEST TO ANSWER
THE- THE OUTCOME OF THESE TOOLS
AGAIN WE JUST HELP WITH MORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TECHNOLOGY
IN THE PROCUREMENT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
NOT TO JUMP AHEAD I'M GOING TO
GO TO IF YOU WERE DONE I WAS
GOING TO GO TO- VICE CHAIR BATES
BUT ISN'T THE CURE MEANT A PART
OF- HOW A SELECTION OCCURS YOU
PUT TOGETHER THE PROCUREMENT I
KNOW IN AS PART OF PROCUREMENT
IT'S ARE YOU ALSO REACHING OUT
AND BE IN DIVERSE AND THE AND
THE POTENTIAL. CONTRACTORS THAT
YOU MIGHT OR CONTRACTS YOU MIGHT
BUT ISN'T PROCUREMENT IN AND OF
ITSELF. THE ART OF SELECTING-
TECHNOLOGY OR WHATEVER THE IT IS
WHATEVER THE PROCUREMENT IS FOR
. YES SENATOR- YES PROCUREMENT
IS ENDING IT IS A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS AND- WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY WITH OUR
PROCUREMENT OF TECHNOLOGY THERE
IS SOME- TOOLS THAT YOU CAN BUY
THAT- BETTER ON ASIA IT'S CALLED
A- I GET A LIST THAT YOU CAN BE
ON POINT BLANK FIVE BY THAT AND
AGAIN YOU USUALLY YOU SEND OUT-
DIFFERENT. BIDS SO THAT YOU GET
THE BEST BID AND YOU CAN ALSO
EVALUATE- THE CRITERIA SO AND
AGAIN WHAT WE WHAT MY ROLE IS
REALLY ASK PROGRAM AREAS WHAT IS
THE CRITERIA. FOR LOOKING AT
THIS TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T MEET
YOUR CRITERIA- AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THE PROGRAMMER IS TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
EFFECTIVE- THAT MEETS THEIR
GOALS FOR THEIR DEPARTMENT. I
SEE. SO THE THING YOU YOU
PROCURE IS SEPARATE FROM THE
CONSIDER THE IN HOUSE OF
COMPUTER I. T. PEOPLE WHO WOULD
THEN BE USING IT SO. THEY THEY
SEEM TO BE TO SEPT OKAY I
UNDERSTAND YES. I'M I'M GONNA
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
MISS MONTGOMERY I'M GOING TO GO
TO VICE CHAIR BATES NEXT.
ADVISED HERE ARE YOU READY.
I
JUST MADE A SPEECH THAT NONE OF
YOU HEARD YOUR MIND. BUT I'M
SURE IT WAS BRILLIANT MANIFIESTO
HERE YEAH IT'S JUST LETTING YOU
KNOW YES I WAS READY BUT I WAS
TRYING TO GET MY PAPERS IN ORDER
HERE SO. ANYWAY I THINK YOU BOTH
OFF FOR- STEPPING FORWARD AND
JOB BEING IN THIS PROFESSION FOR
AS LONG AND CERTAINLY- AS
EFFECTIVELY AS YOU HAVE DONE
BASED ON YOUR RESUME STAND OUT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
POSED TO YOU IN THE EARLY
INTERVIEWS- I WOULD LIKE TO
START WITH MISS LOPEZ WITH A FEW
FOLLOW UPS THAT I HAVE AND I AM
BEING ACCOMMODATED I'M WORKING
FROM MY DISTRICT OFFICE. SO I
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
INTERVIEW YOU BET SO I HAVE
REVIEWED THE MATERIAL YOU KNOW
AND- I WILL CITE CONCERNS ABOUT
START WITH MISS LOPEZ WITH- THE-
DATA ON CDC ARE- THE
APPLICATIONS FOR OFFICERS HAS
DROPPED SIGNIFICANTLY. I THINK
40% YEAR OVER YEAR AND NOW 50%
WHEN COMPARED SHOT OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS CERTAINLY CORBIN MIGHT
HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IN PERHAPS A
PRISON CLOSURES OR PLAYING A
ROLE AND THE JOB SECURITY THAT
MIGHT BE OF CONCERN TO THOSE
STEPPING FORWARD TO GET INTO
THIS PROFESSION. BUT I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE FIVE
WAYS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING OUT TO
RECRUIT MORE OFFICERS AND ALSO
ADDRESS THE DIVERSITY ISSUE AND
I THINK THAT WILL SPECIFICALLY
INTO GETTING ARE ALL WOMEN HI
INVOLVED IN THIS PROFESSION. AND
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY DIFFICULT
ESPECIALLY WITH YOU KNOW THE
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND THE ABILITY TO
REALLY REACH OUT PERSON TO
PERSON AND SHARE I'LL PROBABLY
WHICH YOU WOULD IF YOU'RE STILL
THERE MISS LOPEZ I THINK YOU
WOULD DEFINE IT AS A GLORIOUS
CLEAR CAREER THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT. THAT ARE MAYBE
SHARE AYE YOU'RE FIVE- THE FIVE
WAYS THAT YOU ARE HIGHLIGHTED IN
YOUR GOALS ON THE WAY YOU'RE
DOING THAT HOW WE SHARE WITH US
HOW THAT'S WORKING- YEAH AND- IF
THERE'S OTHER. THINGS. THAT
YOU'VE LEARNED ALONG THE WAY
THAT WORK BETTER- OR NOT SO WELL
ABSOLUTELY CENTER RATES THANK
YOU MUCH FOR QUESTION- YOU KNOW
I EIGHT YEARS. OF MY WITH HE'S
OFFICER SELECTION PLAY
DEVELOPMENTS WITH WHICH OAK WITH
. OVER RECRUITMENT FOR OFFICERS
AND TRAINING OF OFFICERS AND SO
WE DID WHAT WE WRAPPED UP THE
ACADEMY IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
AND FOURTEEN WE SAW QUITE A FEW
APPLICATIONS DURING THAT TIME WE
RECEIVING PROBABLY FOUR TO FIVE
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS A MONTH.
AT ONE POINT WE PROBABLY HAVE
THIRTY THOUSAND APPLICATIONS
THAT WERE IN PROCESS WE DID SEE
A DECLINE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WITH THE APPLICATIONS
COMING IN. AND THAT WAS REALLY
ACROSS THE BOARD THAT WAS NATION
WIDE IT WAS NOT- JUST- IT WAS
NOT JUST IMPACTING CDC ARE- WE
BUILT A VERY ROBUST A
RECRUITMENT PROGRAM- THIS
STARTED WHEN- THE ACADEMY RE
OPENED AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. AND CREATED A
STATEWIDE RECRUITMENT TEAM- THAT
WAS HELPING OUT WITH ALL OF
THESE JOB FAIRS THEY WERE
TENDING- ALL THE RECRUITMENT
WITH THE MILITARY- SO THERE IS A
RECRUITMENT FOR. A SPECIAL
RECRUITMENT FEMALE LIKE YOU.
YEAH WE DID SEE AN INCREASE WE
CONTINUE TO SEE AN INCREASE IN
FEMALES- OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
EVEN WITH THE DECLINE IN
APPLICATIONS- BUT DEFINITELY- WE
WERE VERY STRATEGIC IN HOW WE
WERE RECRUITING YOU KNOW I WOULD
GET QUESTIONS. ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS HOW COME I'M NOT
SEEING MORE OF THIS GROUP OR
THAT GROUP YOU KNOW I GRADUATION
WHAT DO Y'ALL DO WE- SO WE WERE
CONSTANTLY BEING CHALLENGED YOU
KNOW BY FOLKS WHO WERE ASKING
WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT
RECRUITMENT. AND THE RECRUITMENT
TEAM IS EXTRAORDINARY- UP FOR
CDCR CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT WHAT
ALL THE WORK THEY DO- ON A DAILY
BASIS AND EVEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE ALSO HAD THEIR-
CONVERTS TO BIRCH YOU'LL LIKE
YOU KNOW THE WHOLE WORLD. AND SO
TRYING TO DO VIRTUAL FARES AND-
GET PEOPLE TO COME- HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING BUT THEY CONTINUE TO
GET MORE APPLICATIONS. AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE TYPICALLY
SEE A DECLINE AROUND THE
HOLIDAYS AND THEN THE NUMBERS
INCREASE- AFTER IT USUALLY IN
JANUARY FEBRUARY. WE ACTUALLY
SAW AN INCREASE IN DECEMBER. AND
SO NOT QUITE SURE WHY BUT WE DID
SEE A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE ONE
OF THE PROBABLY ONE OF THE
BIGGEST WE'VE SEEN IN PROBABLY A
YEAR AND A HALF- I WILL SAY
THOUGH THE RECRUITMENT HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL AS FAR OUT AS WE
HAVE. MAINTAINED THE ACADEMY- WE
FILL THE ACADEMY EVERY- CHANCE
THAT WE GET WE HAVE NOT HAD A
TIME WHERE WE DID NOT HAVE
PEOPLE IN. OUR PROCESS TO GO TO
THE ECONOMY AND WE CONTINUE TO
INCREASE OUR NUMBERS OF FEMALES.
IT IS DIFFICULT AT TIMES TO GET
THE EMAILS AND WE HAD REACHED
OUT. TO A NUMBER OF OUR
APPLICANTS AND PARTLY BECAUSE WE
HAVE ONE ACADEMY THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND ITS SINGLES SO IT
CAN BE- YOU KNOW. AND FOR MALE
APPLICANTS AS WELL CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO BE AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES FOR THIRTEEN
WEEKS- BUT THERE'S WE ARE
ACTUALLY ENTERING INTO APPROACH.
PROGRAMMATIC MARKETING
CONTRACTOR. FURTHER EXPAND OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THIS WILL
INCLUDE FOR RECRUITING PEACE
OFFICERS AND AS WELL AS NON
PEACE OFFICERS BECAUSE WE DO.
HAVE SOME CHALLENGES WITH
RECRUITING SOME OF OUR NON PEACE
OFFICER CLASSIFICATIONS AS
MENTIONED EARLIER- BUT I'M
REALLY AGAIN PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT'S NOT BY THE RECRUITMENT
TEAM FOR CDC ARE. THEY AREN'T
WORKING NONSTOP. AND TRYING TO
KEEP PEOPLE YOU KNOW GET PEOPLE
TO APPLY. WE'RE DOING- WE'VE
TRIED WE'VE DONE THIS IN THE
PAST IT'S CALLED THE ONE STOP
HIRING. AND IN THOSE HARD TO
FILL LOCATIONS. SUCH AS
SUSANVILLE- SANK A MARIN COUNTY-
A PELICAN BAY AREA. CITY. SO
WHAT WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
AND STOP SO THEY WERE SIX. WE
DID THIS A YOU. SIX AS THEY
HAVE- ONE STOP HIRING WHERE YOU
CAN COME IN AND APPLY TAKE THE
WRITTEN EXAM AND THAT'S TWO
STEPS OUT OF THE SELECTION
PROCESS RIGHT THERE THAT THEY
CAN ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE. BECAUSE
ANOTHER CHALLENGE WE WOULD GET
WAS BIG THAT PEOPLE COULDN'T
TRAVEL TO CERTAIN AREAS AND- WE
DID EXPAND ON THAT AS FAR AS
WHERE WE WERE RECRUITINGAND
WHERE WE CAN ACCOMMODATE MORE
PEOPLE. WE WERE A COMEDY EATING-
APPLICANTS ON THE WEEKENDS WE
ARE DOING- EVENING RECRUITMENT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW PEOPLE HAVE
REGULAR JOBS DURING THE DAY. SO
THERE'S BEEN SO MANY DIFFERENT
EFFORTS OVER THE YEARS YEAH-
THEY CONTINUE TO THINK OF MORE
TO SEE HOW WE CAN GET MORE
APPLICANTS AND AGAIN NOT ONLY
FOR PEACE OFFICERS. BUT FOR OUR
NON PEACE OFFICER
CLASSIFICATIONS SUCH AS COOKS.
OF PLANT OPERATIONS- AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. VERY GOOD I
AM SPEAKING OUT THEIR JOB FAIRS
ALL OVER THE STATE AND CERTAINLY
MANY OF US ARE LEGISLATORS
HAVEL'S JOB FAIRS OR OUR PARTNER
WITH THEM SO. PROBABLY IMPORTANT
TO KEEP US DIALED IN ON THAT
ALSO. ANOTHER ON REFLECTION I AM
THE FOCUS ON- THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM IN THE
REHABILITATION PART OF THAT.
MIGHT BE SOMETHING BASS FROM THE
MORE INTEREST TO THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING A CAREER IN CORRECTIONS
ARE YOU DOING MUCH TO USE THAT
AS A FOCUSED ESPECIALLY WITH OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE FOLLOWING.
I THINK ARE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
CAREER STUFF THEY LOOK AT IN A
LOT OF PEOPLE COME THROUGH. I
THINK HE'S PSYCHOLOGY SOCIOLOGY
OF- THOSE ARE PEOPLE LOOKING I
THINK TO WORK IN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS A MEANINGFUL. CAREER
PATH HI HAVE YOU TRIED TO USE
THAT IN YOUR MARKETING IN YOUR
OUT OF REACH. YES I ALSO WOULD
NOT AMOUNT F HOUSING PEOPLE
ANYMORE IT'S REALLY TRY. TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM IN AND GIVE
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
LOT. OF WHEN THEY'VE MADE SOME
MISTAKES IN THE EARLIER YEARS SO
BOB TO ME THAT NOT THAT SHOULD
BE A COMPELLING ARGUMENT TOO.
MANY IN OUR YOUNGER GENERATION.
HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR SOME OF
THEM. YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND IN THE
BEGINNING- YOU KNOW MANY OF THE
ADVERTISEMENTS WHEN WE FIRST
WERE OPENING MORE. FOCUS MORE ON
WHAT THE BENEFITS AND THE
PAPERWORK WAS PROVIDED AS YOU
KNOW COMING IN AS A NEW SEO. AND
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE TRANSFORMED
THAT MESSAGING- TO
REHABILITATION AND THEN ALL THE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- TO AND APPLICANT WHO
WANTS TO JOIN CPEC YARD THEY MAY
NOT WANT TO. SEE A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER THE WHOLE CAREER THERE'S
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELOR. THERE'S
A SPECIAL AGENTS THERE'S PAROLE
AGENT SO A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTING- AS FAR AND THIS
AGAIN HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR THE
LAST PROBABLY EIGHT NINE YEARS.
WITH REGARDS TO OUR RECRUITMENT
SO YES DEFINITELY DID CHANGE THE
MESSAGING- WITH REGARDS TO OUR
RECRUITING TO GET MORE PEOPLE
AND NOT JUST- FOLKS WHO WANTED
TO BE A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER YOU
KNOW FOR THEIR THEIR WHOLE
CAREER WHICH IS FINE AS WELL. SO
HAVE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES- IN
OTHER. PROSECUTIONS WITHIN CDCR
. THANK YOU FOR THE ARE LITTLE
FOR RESPOND. BOTH HOUSING AND
CERTAINLY YOU WILL HAVE MY
SUPPORT SO WHEN WE GET TO THE
TONIGHT I AGAIN WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
DEFICIT SO VERY IMPORTANT JOB.
THE AGENCY IN OUR GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE THAT OUR PEOPLE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY THOSE I
AS I MENTIONED. IN MY TO GOT OFF
ON THE ON THE WRONG FOOT EARLY
ON AND JOB NEED TO BE BACK AND
BE A ROBUST PART OF OUR
CITIZENRY SO. THANK YOU AND I
WILL MOVE TO MISS MONTGOMERY-
AND AGAIN THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
WHILE MEDIAN THIS VERY IMPORTANT
AGENCY ARE YOU ONE STOP
CONCERNED ABOUT- THE USE OF OUR
TECHNOLOGY AND IN PARTICULAR THE
LAPTOPS AND THE- THE ACCESS THAT
ARE ON INMATES NOW HAVE WHO ARE
GOOD NEWS INVOLVED IN THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT FOR EARLY
RELEASE ETCETERA BUT IN THE
BUDGET TALKING MY NUMBERS HERE
CRAP TO HOLD TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWO THE BUDGET
PROVIDED. TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND LAPTOPS THAT ASSUMING
THAT OF THOSE INMATES- AT LEAST
THAT MANY OR OR THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR THAT MANY
ON WHO WOULD WANT TO YOU KNOW
TAKE UP THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
THAT COULD LEAD. TO ESPECIALLY
TO EARLIER RELIEF AND IDEALLY
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR MISUSE OF THOSE
AND I THINK WE DISCUSSED THAT
WITH ONE OF THE PREVIOUS
APPOINTMENTS FACT I'D LIKE TO
KNOW IF WE ARE MONITORING THE
INMATES USE OF HAT TECHNOLOGY
ESPECIALLY THEIR EMAIL
COMMUNICATIONS. SO THAT THEY'RE
NOT. ABLE TO- A RELAPSE AND IN
SOME ACTIVITY OR IN ANY SORT OF
HARASSMENT THAT CAN GO ON IF YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY SO YOU CAN SHARE SOME
OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT IF YOU
HAVE THE INFORMATION I KNOW THAT
IT WAS SOMETHING OF- PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN IN THE IN
OUR LAST DISCUSSIONS ON ON THIS
BUDGET APPROPRIATION. THANK
SENATOR- YES WE HAVE JUST
STARTED- WORKING ON THIS-
PROJECT AND- I FIND IT VERY
EXCITING- THE FIRST THING THAT
WE- ARE ARE DOING IT IS REALLY
LOOKING AT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SO I TALK ABOUT THAT IT'S
REALLY ARE- THE NETWORK. AND THE
SERVERS AND EVERYTHING THAT
SUPPORTS THE UNDERLYING-
LAPTOPS. SO THE REASON WHY
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT TO THIS ONE
AS YOU- WHEN YOU ARE GOING TO
GET THAT MANY LAPTOPS I YOU
FIRST HAVE TO HAVE A BAND WITH
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE INFORMATION- AND
SECONDLY WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
SECURITY COMPONENTS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THE GROUND AND IT
WOULD BE SEPARATE SO THE INPUT
WE CALL INCARCERATED NETWORK
VERSES ARE STAFFED WITH THAT
HAVE A TOTALLY SEPARATED IT SO
THAT- WE MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
MONITOR IT FROM THAT STANDPOINT
SECURITY IS VERY IMPORTANT- IN
MY ROLE AND- WE ARE BUILDING. TO
THAT- RIGHT RIGHT NOW IN FACT.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE- DEPART THAT PROGRAMS-
REHABILITATION PROGRAM. AND
WHAT'S ON THESE LAPTOPS IT- THEY
ARE PUTTING A LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO THAT'S
REALLY HOW THEY'RE ACESSING THE
INFORMATION SO IT'S REALLY LIKE-
HOW ALL THIS EXPLAINED LIKE IT'S
ONE WAY UP THERE'S NO AND YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO THE
INTERNET BUT YOU ARE VERY YOU
HAVE THE SECURITY AROUND THAT
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE ACCESSING
THEIR CLASSES YES FOR THE
PUTTING THE HOMEWORK AND THAT
TYPE OF THING. SO FROM THAT
STANDPOINT- THEY CAN DO I THINK
SOME MESSAGES WITH YOUR TEACHER
INSIDE THE APPLICATION BUT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
EMAIL OR GET INTO THE INTERNET-
AND WE DO HAVE THE MONITORING
TOOLS ON THAT- THAT'S GOOD NEWS
BECAUSE I THINK HAT THERE WAS
A- PERHAPS AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHAT YOU HAVE THAT. YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE FULL ACCESS. AND I
SEE THE BALANCE THAT YOU HAVE
THE YOU YOU ANTICIPATED THAT IN
THE NEXT. DAY YOU GAVE OF COURSE
AND WAS A NEEDED TO BE OUT ASK
OUR- FELT I NEEDED TO DO THAT
BASED ON THE LAST. ON
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE SO WITH-
THIS NUMBER THANK YOU AGAIN I
DON'T HAVE ARE THERE OTHER. BUT
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO MY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
SOME- CERTAINLY TO ASK ABOUT THE
EVD ARE. UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AND ALL THAT SO- I WILL LET THAT
GO AND SAY THANK YOU AGAIN AND
YOU WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT WHEN WE
GOT TO. THE POINT OF BOB THE
MOTION AND- TO- MOVIE FORWARD.
FOR CONFIRMATION SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR LET
ME MOVE NOW TO SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU I'M NOT IMPRESSED HIM
VERY MUCH AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY ASKING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU LADIES I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR AND. I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT TO CALL IT YOU
KNOW IT WHEN WE TAKE THE OATH OF
OFFICE STATE AND WE HAVE TO
SWEAR IN OUR STAFF THAT SAYS WE
TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
WITHOUT ANY TEAM ANY MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION AND FOR EVERYTHING GOING
ON. IN THE CDC OUR SYSTEM WITH
KOBE AGAIN. I MEAN EVERYTHING I
JUST APPLIED YOU BOTH FOR
STANDING UP AND THEM. AND TAKING
THESE POSITIONS AND- AND WORKING
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY FOR THEIR SAFETY INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE THE PRISON SYSTEM. BUT
ALSO FOR THE WORKERS AND- YOU
KNOW THAT THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
SERVED IN THAT IN THAT CAPACITY
AS WELL. KEEPING THE INTERNET
SAFE AND SECURE. AND SO I
APPLAUD YOU FOR- BEING WILLING
TO TAKE ON THIS ROLE. AS I DO AS
I MISS LOPEZ I'LL START WITH YOU
IF THAT'S OKAY. IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION AND IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE STATE AUDITOR
REPORTED THAT CDC ARE FAILED TO
ENSURE A REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WORK. AND EVIDENCE BASED AND
EFFECTIVE IN WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THE RECIDIVISM. YOU
KNOW THAT WE DON'T HAVE A HIGH
RECIDIVISM THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
DON'T GO BACK INTO PRISON AND
THAT. AND THAT THEIR SUCCESSFUL-
AND GET A JOB AND BECOME
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
AS WE WANT TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
SO- WHAT STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
TO IMPROVE THAT- IMPROVE THAT SO
THAT THEIR EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS FAITH BASED PROGRAMS
PROGRAMS THAT REALLY WORK- AND
IS THERE A STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE TO- DIRECT. OF FORMER
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
THESE PROGRAMS SO THEY CAN HAVE
A BETTER CHANCE OF SUCCESS.
OUTSIDE THE PRISON SYSTEM. THE
SENATOR OF THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- THIS IS NOT UNDER MY
PURVIEW SO I WOULD SORRY THAT'S
OKAY I WOULD BE ABLE TO RESPOND-
IF YOU TODAY BUT WE CAN
DEFINITELY- GET SOME INFORMATION
REGARDING YOUR QUESTIONS ON THIS
PIECE. OF IT FALLS WITH UNDER
WITH IN OUR DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS- BUT WE
CAN DEFINITELY GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE QUESTIONS RELATED TO THAT
AND HOW THAT WORKS. OKAY AND I'M
SORRY I HAD A WRONG QUESTION FOR
YOU I WAS REALLY. THE ANSWER TO
THAT. AND BECAUSE I WORK WITH A
LOT OF COLLABORATIONS IN WE DO A
LOT OF COLLABORATIONS WITH NON
PROFITS AND- AND I SEE- I SEE
SOME PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A REALLY
REALLY REALLY GOOD. A SUCCESS
RATE. IN PEOPLE DO BECAUSE I'M
REALLY RESPONSIBLE. AND
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
AND I ENJOY WATCHING THEIR
JOURNEY YOU KNOW AND- JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE I HAVE A AND
IT A JURY YOU KNOW. LOPEZ THAT
LIKE A TARGET TIED TO HIS HEAD
YOU'RE DRESSED DOWN HIS FACE AND
I DON'T KNOW STUFF ALL OVER HIM.
AND HE IS NOW ON THAT HEAD OF
THE PTA FOR HIS AND SEVEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER AND- SO I AM. IT
TAKES A MINUTE TO GET PASS. THE
WAY HE LETS THAT WHEN YOU GET
PAST THAT HE IS THE MOST GENUINE
KIND PERSON. AND YOU'LL EVER
MEET AND SO I WAS VERY EXCITED
TO HEAR ABOUT THAT AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT. AND KNOWING
THAT WAS NOT UNDER YOUR PURVIEW
SO PLEASE FORGIVE ME- THAT'S
OKAY DEFINITELY WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION AND I AGREE I THINK.
HERE THE STORIES IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND- TO SEE PEOPLE BE
SUCCESSFUL- THROUGH OUR
REHABILITATION I MEAN THAT'S-
THAT'S WHAT WE DO. SO HOW DO
YOU. NOT WANT. LESS. ONLY
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU SO-
GOODNESS MY CAMERA IF THAT'S
OKAY MISS MCENERY AND- AT.
SURVEYS HIS BEEN PROVEN DETER
CRIMINAL. IN AND THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND A DVR. IT'S ALSO BEEN
AND- I THINK AS- A DETERMINANT
FACTOR WHEN- THAT PROTECTS BOTH
THE INMATE AND THE GUARD OR AND
THE CDC ARE- REPRESENTATIVE. SO
CAN YOU TELL ME- IF THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE ENSURING THAT
BIG SURVEILLANCE IS BEING USED
AS INTENDED BECAUSE I REALLY DO
THINK THAT AND IT DOES HELP
PROTECT EVERYONE INVOLVED. YES
THANK YOU FOR QUESTION- OF MY
ROLE IN THE DEPARTMENT IS TO
IMPLEMENT THE CAMERAS AND TO PUT
ALL INFRASTRUCTURE IN FOR THAT.
THE AFFECTED THIS OF THE CAMERAS
AND THAT THEY'RE USING THEM- WE
MONITOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S- THE CAMERAS ARE DOWN SO
IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE BROKEN OR
THAT TYPE OF THING WILL BE-
WORKING WITH- OUR VENDOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FIX THE CAMERAS AND
THAT TYPE OF THING- BUT AS FAR
AS- THERE YOU SET UP. ACTIVENESS
WE WOULD UP AGAIN I'D HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE PROGRAM AREAS TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION FOR YOU.
OKAY ENGINEERING'S YOU ANSWER
AND A QUESTION ABOUT HOW THE
CDCR IS CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. ON AND EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE CARE TO PREVENT PROBLEMS
FRAUDULENT CLAIM FILING AND-
BECAUSE WE DID YOU KNOW THE I
DID SHOW THERE WERE SEVERAL
INDIVIDUALS INSIDE THE CD R. CD
SEE OUR SYSTEM. THAT WERE ILING
AND HE NEEDS. HUGE AMOUNTS OF
RESOURCES AND FROM THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THAT CAN EITHER OF
YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE ON THAT IS
THAT IN EITHER OF YOUR CRISIS
PERFUMES. THAT DOESN'T BREATH
PREVIEW- YEAH WE WORKED WITH-
EDT AND WE PUT A DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COULD SHARE THE DATA
WITH THEM. AND WE DO HAVE A
REGULAR DATA SHARING- WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM TO GIVE THEM
THE NECESSARY. DATA AND THEY
WERE ASKING EARLIER THIS YEAR
FOR SOME OTHER DATA WE ARE ABLE
TO UPDATE THAT DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT AND BE ABLE TO RIDE IN
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED. SO AT
THIS POINT IN TIME- WE'VE- WE'VE
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM AND THEY
HAVE TOLD US THEY'RE GETTING THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT. AND YOU
KNOW IT'S IF IT'S BEEN FOUND TO
BE EFFECTIVE OR DO YOU HAVE ANY
AND I. GOT IT I DON'T HAVE
FEEDBACK OR WHETHER IT WAS OF
AFFECTED BY MY ASSUMPTION WOULD
BE YES THEY ARE- BUT I'VE- I'VE
YOU'D HAVE.I GET I HAVE TO GO
TO A PROGRAM WHERE WE HAVE TO
ASK EDT. OKAY WELL I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING YES ON ON YOUR
CRISIS YOU BOTH HAVE YOUR
CONFIRMATIONS AGAIN. WHAT A HARD
HARD POSITION THAT YOU ARE BEING
APPOINTED. TO WHEN I JUST
APPLIED BOTH OF YOU FOR. I MEAN
THE COURAGE THIS. TO TO TAKE THE
POSITION SO- AGAIN I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING I AND I WISH
YOU BOTH THE BEST OF LUCK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR LAYERED. GOOD TO DO
QUOTE OUR LEADER THE CHAIR IT IS
ALWAYS IS GOOD TO GO NEAR LAST
BECAUSE ALMOST EVERYTHING HAS
BEEN ASKED SO. I HAD A END OF IT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SIT THROUGH A LONG HEARING
BEFORE YOU'VE GOT TO A LONG
HEARING. AND SO SENATOR GROVE
JUST ASKED WHAT I WAS GOING TO
TALK TO. THE TO KRISTEN MY
PRIMARY ABOUT IN. IT AND WE HAD
A GREAT MEETING. OUR OUR
YESTERDAY WITH BOTH OF YOU AND I
FELT LIKE IT REALLY HELPED ME
WITH WHAT I NEEDED AND SO. ON
THE CAMERA ISSUE I WAS GOING TO
ASK WITH THAT WAS DISPATCHED AND
SOLD THEM FOR. FOR STACEY LOPEZ
THE ONE THING I WOULD ASK. WE
TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY IN THE
MEETING THAT THERE. IN MY PRIOR
INCARNATION IN THE LEGISLATURE
THERE WAS THAT BUDGET THAT I
MENTIONED TO YOU. THAT IS REALLY
ANCIENT HISTORY BY. ARE THE
BUDGET WAS PASSED AND TOOK SIX
MONTHS FOR THE SYSTEM TO ENTERED
INTO THEIR BOOKS AND THEY'D
ALREADY OVERSPENT THE BUDGET BY
A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
THEY HADN'T EVEN ENTERED IT INTO
THE BOOKS TO KNOW THAT IT WAS.
LOWER IN SOME ACCOUNTS THAN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. AND OF COURSE YOU
. MEDIA WE SAID HOW MUCH THAT
WAS ANCIENT HISTORY OF BUT I
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO TALK ABOUT
JUST SORT OF THE EFFICIENCY AND
HOW IT WORKS NOW AND YOUR-
RESPONSIBILITY IN THAT SO WE
JUST HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE. OF
WHERE THAT STANDS IN THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU SAID
EARLIER YES I CAN ADDRESS THAT
DEFINITELY- YEAH SO I THINK THAT
WAS ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND THREE
BUT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT AND I
RECALL BECAUSE I WAS WORKING FOR
THE STATE AT THAT TIME SOWE
HAVE COME A LONG WAY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THREE- WE HAVE A
BUSINESS BUSINESS INFORMATION
SYSTEM WHICH FALLS I'M UNDER
PERSONS AREA SO AS I MENTIONED
YESTERDAY IF THERE'S ANY ISSUES
ABOUT THAT. SO I TALKED TO MY
COLLEAGUE OVER IT- YEAH IDEAS TO
HELP OUT BUT THE SYSTEM ITSELF-
IS BEEN WORKING IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE TRACKING OUR
EXPENDITURES AND KEEPING AND
HOLDING OUR PROGRAMS
INSTITUTIONS ACCOUNTABLE WE HAVE
AN AVAILABILITY CONTROL THAT IS
WITHIN- RPI YES FOR THIS SYSTEM.
THAT DOES NOT ALLOW PROGRAMS
INSTITUTIONS TO GO BEYOND WHAT
THEIR ALLOTMENT. SO THAT'S A
DEFINITELY A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
FROM- TWO THOUSAND THREE- SO
WITH THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
PHYSICAL REVIEWS THAT WE HOLD
WITH OUR PROGRAMS AND
INSTITUTIONS AND THEN THE
TRAINING THAT WE PROVIDE. AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE CONSISTENTLY ARE
CONSTANTLY MEETING WITH OUR
PROGRAMS INSTITUTIONS ON THEIR
BUDGET SO WHILE WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE WE ARE
ALSO DOING A NUMBER OF OTHER
THINGS TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE.
STAYS WITHIN THEIR BUDGET
ALLOTMENT. THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR APPRECIATE THEIR
SPOTS TO THE QUESTION. THANK YOU
WELL HI THANK YOU BOTH AYE YEAH
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE YOU
SET THROUGH. A LONG HEARING
ALREADY I ONLY HAVE ONE OCT SORT
OF DESTROYED TO QUESTION- FOR
YOU MISS MONTGOMERY- I KNOW THAT
I'M FAMILIAR OR WHERE THAT- THE
CDC ARE TESTIFIED YESTERDAY I IN
THE BUDGET SUB FIVE. RELATED TO
OUR CAMERAS OF THE BODY WORN
CAMERA REPORTS AND REALLY THE
ONLY QUESTION I HAD IS HAVE YOU
HOW HAS IT HAPPENED- HAVE YOU
ADVISE THE WARDENS IN TERMS OF
DEALING WITH CAMERA SHUT OFFS
CAN YOU KIND OF SHARE A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT. WITH ME. FOR AND AS
IT RELATES TO BODY WORN CAMERAS-
THERE IS PROCEDURES THAT- THE
PROGRAMS HAVE PUT IN PLACE WHERE
WHERE THEY CAN SHUT THE ACTUAL
BODY WORN CAMERA OFF. AND SO IF
THERE IF THE BODY WORN CAMERAS
SHUT OFF FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME THE REPORTS THAT- THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE PROGRAM AREAS
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO- GO WORK
WITH THE- INDIVIDUAL THAT HAD-
BODY WORN CAMERA SHUT OFF FOR A
TIME BEING- BUT REALLY IT'S FIVE
DONE THROUGH POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IS NOT DONE THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY WAS REGARDS. THE BODY
WORN CAMERAS. AS AS FAR AS THE
FIXED CAMERAS WE DO- MONITOR
THOSE WE DO HAVE MONITORING
SOFTWARE ON THAT- AND SO THAT
FROM A TECHNOLOGY STANDPOINT WE
WILL KNOW WHETHER CAMERAS ON OR
OFF. THANK YOU- THAT WAS I
ACTUALLY ALL I HAD I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSES- TWO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC EYE NOW
AND- WE'RE GONNA START OKAY. DID
I FORGET SOMETHING- MS CALL
THEMSELVES OF THE SENATOR GROVE
I'M SO SORRY LET ME JUST THANK
OUR SECRETARY FOR MAKING SURE I
DON'T OVERLOOK YOUR RAISED HAND
GO HEAD. NO IT'S ACTUALLY IT'S A
POOR TIMING ISSUE NOW I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT. SPEAKING UP
SOONER BUT I JUST EVEN THOUGH
I'M NOT THERE IN PERSON I DON'T
WANT TO GO WITHOUT AND-
CHASTISING AND OURS ARE GOOD
COLLEAGUE THAT THE FORMER
SECRETARY SENATOR LAYERED HE
ALMOST. MADE ME A VERY NICE
COMPLIMENT IN HE SAID A KIND OF
WATCHES WORDS JUST A CAT. MADAM
CHAIR LET ME JUST SAY I'M NOT ON
THE BALLOT FOR THREE YEARS SO I
COULD PROBABLY SUSTAIN THE KIND
WORDS FOR SENATOR GROW. I LOVE
THAT JUST DOES FOR OUR
APPOINTEES WHO ARE PATIENTLY
WAITING. LET ME SAY YOU'RE NOT
THE ONLY TWO ON THE HOT SEAT IN
THE MIDDLE OF A SENATE.
CONFIRMATION HEARING YOU YOU'RE
PROBABLY YOU'RE SMILING SO
YOU'RE PLEASED TO SEE THAT. ALL
RIGHT NOW YOU SEE WHAT I DEAL
WITH EVERY DAY- NO THANK YOU ARE
WE DO ENJOY THE CONVERSATION AND
BEING ABLE TO TALK WITH
APPOINTEES WE LEARNED A LOT AND-
AS YOU CAN SEE WE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT OUR COLLEAGUES AS WELL. SO
I AM GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. AND I'M GONNA START IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AND I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE APPROACHING
THE PODIUM- SO I AM GOING TO GO
BACK TO OUR INCREDIBLE MODERATOR
WHO IS WAITING. TO SEE IF SHE
WOULD PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND AS RIGHT
BEFORE SHE DOES THAT I'M GOING
TO REMIND PEOPLE AGAIN. OUR FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO GIVE TESTIMONY
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION IF ANY YOUR
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT.
AGAIN SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY
AND WITH THAT MADAME MODERATOR
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO YOU
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO PUBLIC LIFESTYLE BUT AT
THIS TIME. OKAY I'M SURE I'M
GONNA BE BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A
MOMENT- SO GIVEN THAT THERE WAS
NO ONE- MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE LET
ME SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE. IN
OPPOSITION HERE. AGAIN SEEING NO
ONE HERE IN OPPOSITION MADAME
MODERATOR- BACK TO YOU FOR
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WE HAVE
NO LIFESTYLE THAT OVER THE PHONE
. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP TODAY-
WITH THAT- HAVEN'T GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
TO SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION.
SENATOR LAYERED I AM PREPARED TO
MOVE BOTH APPOINTMENTS THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AS I BUT AS WE GO TO THE VOTE I
AM REMINDED BY MY SECRETARY- ON
TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY I AM TOLD
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY ALSO AS YOU
VOTE ON THE ITEM AND THE NAMES
THAT I WILL HELP YOU IF NEED BE
AT THAT TIME. SO THE NAMES OF
THE APPOINTEES- MS LOPEZ AND
MISS MONTGOMERY SO WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL. KAMLAGER HI I'M
MARGARET I LAYERED HI THERE I
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. GO
AHEAD SENATOR YOU'RE ON I'M
SORRY I KEEP PUTTING IT ON YOU
SO YOU DON'T HEAR THE TRAFFIC
NOISE ON THE BACK NINE. YES- ON
ITEM ONE DEEP STACEY LOCALES. HE
KRISTIN MONTGOMERY SENATOR BATES
HI THANK YOU SENATOR. BATES I.
GROWTH GIRL I'M GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED TO APPEAR
ITEM D. STACEY LOPEZ AND ITEM HE
KRISTIN MAKE CAMERI GROWTH I
GROW I FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IT IS UNANIMOUS WE
WILL FORWARD THESE- APPOINTMENTS
ON TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR A
FULL CONFIRMATION LET ME SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOUR
TIME AND YOUR SERVICE HOPE YOU
HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. COM OKAY. GO TO MY
SCRIPT AT THE END WE ARE-
CONCLUDING TODAY'S PUBLIC
PORTION OF OUR AGENDA I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY AND IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING YOU CAN STILL DO THAT TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE SURE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOUR
COOPERATION ARE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON RULES WILL NOW MOVE TO
EXECUTIVE SESSION.